So, muss grad noch schnell Zähne putzen gehen, hab ich grad vergessen, aber jetzt bin ich da.
Oh, die Twitter Spambots, oh sorry, die X, der Name ist so dämlich, Alter.
Die X Spambots sind wieder am Start.
Was kommt als nächstes? Als nächstes wird einfach Twitter bzw. X unbedingt irgendein Sonderzeichen,
dass man das noch schlechter suchen kann.
Ich frag mich, ob noch Leute bei Twitter arbeiten, die wirklich dahinterstehen.
Bei ein paar, so ein paar Hardcore Elon Musk Fans wahrscheinlich.
Ich fand's ja am Anfang auch gar nicht schlecht, dass es ein paar Änderungen gibt.
Auch das Verifizierungs- und Hackensystem fand ich prinzipiell nicht verkehrt, dass man das überarbeitet.
Das, was jetzt rausgekommen ist, ist eher so, naja.
Aber diese Gängelung mit Einloggen und also ganz ehrlich, für mich hat Twitter viel von dem verloren,
jetzt die letztes, letztes Jahr über, was es mit ausgemacht hat.
Deswegen hab ich auch immer weniger Bock drauf, irgendwie Twitter wieder zu verwenden.
Ich mein, ich hab teilweise täglich mehrfach getweetet in der Vergangenheit,
jetzt tweet ich irgendwie alle paar Tage mal eine Sache, wenn mir grad irgendwas einfällt.
Also irgendwie hat sich das geändert.
Nicht zum Besseren.
Ich hab erst Java gelesen.
Hab ich gedacht, was hat der Pepo mit Java zu tun?
So, Chatgip, lass uns mal kurz checken.
Was trendet denn auf GitHub diese Woche so?
Hat ja schon Tradition, dass wir das einmal schnell durchgucken im Skript.
Werde wieder alles skippen, was sich langweilig anhört und nach AI.
Geht schon gut los, AI, AI.
China-Chinesen, englische Buchempfehlungen.
AI, vermutlich.
AI.
Notification-Zeug, was nur für Android funktioniert, wahrscheinlich nicht für iOS.
Gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus.
Die App Clock.
Oh.
Achso, da braucht man eine App dafür, okay.
Die ist...
Und die gibt es im App Store?
Oh, gar nicht mal verkehrt.
Okay, das ist ganz cool, dass wir das mittlerweile auch für iOS haben.
Natürlich wird das nie native Push-Notifications ersetzen können,
wenn man irgendeine Anwendung baut oder irgendeine Web-Service baut,
weil das halt eine App braucht.
Open Copilot.
AI.
Die gleichen Sachen jedes Mal trenden.
Ein Switch-Emulator.
AI.
Was ist das denn?
Simple, easy to use, elegant, open source, personal cloud system.
Ist das irgendwas, was Nextcloud Konkurrenz machen will?
Lass mal gucken.
Es ist written in Go.
Es sieht ein bisschen nach Go aus, aber lass mal schauen, ob es Go ist.
Ja, es ist Go.
Was soll das sein?
Es ist so eine...
Soll das so eine Art Nextcloud sein, oder?
Ah.
Moment, nee.
Ach, das ist irgendein Dashboard oder so.
Alter.
Für einen Dashboard ist es aber ganz schön...
...ganz schön großspurig, die Ankündigung, was es angeblich ist.
TS-Folx, dankeschön für den Sub.
Turn any desktop...
Warte mal, Moment.
Turn any webpage into a desktop app with Rust.
Okay, das ist quasi Rust
mit einem Embedded Chrome oder sowas, wahrscheinlich.
Fake.
Das Logo hat...
...quasi ein...
...App...
...ein Website Packager.
Android-Root-Zeug.
Moin.
AI.
Okay.
Ja, das ist besonders spannend.
Es ist diese Woche nicht.
Aber Rechenzentrum.
Bei Dunkelheit. Beste.
So, lass mal überlegen, Chat.
Was gab's die Woche?
Microsoft hat wieder komisches Zeug gepostet,
habe ich im Hintergrund...
Och ja, Leute, ganz, ganz essentiell.
Ihr haltet es nicht für möglich, aber...
...WordPad...
...wird wahrscheinlich aus Windows entfernt, Leute.
Ich habe immer...
Och, nicht. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Word.
Kann ich diesen Shit nicht einfach schließen, Mann?
WordPad.
Hat das...
Ich habe es nie wirklich...
Was heißt nie wirklich? Ich habe es nie verwendet.
Jemand...
Any WordPad-Users?
Haben wir irgendjemand, der das mal benutzt hat?
Also ich habe es wirklich nie benutzt.
Nie.
Und Microsoft sagt jetzt,
jopp, wir wollen es auch nicht mehr.
Weg damit.
Guck mal, die hat einen Button für...
...einen Button für...
...Paint.
Nee, hat es gar nicht mehr. Gibt's nicht mehr.
Nicht WordPress.
So.
Microsoft entfernt das jetzt.
Und natürlich...
...sind wir ein paar Leute.
WordPad.exe.
Sich am Aufregen, aber die meisten...
...fragen sich auch, ja, wer hat das überhaupt benutzt?
Gibt es eigentlich den Windows Movie Maker noch?
Ja.
Den gibt es nicht mehr.
So 2010 rum...
...gab es tatsächlich noch...
...einige YouTube-Videos, die...
...hochgeladen wurden...
...mit Windows Movie Maker.
Und so...
...so mies war ja...
...für die damalige Zeit Windows Movie Maker...
...mal gar nicht.
Jetzt gibt es den Clipchamp. Moment, der Clipchamp...
...ist so eine Art Windows Movie Maker, oder was?
Der Clip...
...Microsoft Clipchamp.
Haben die das von mir, oder wie?
Also wenn ich mich...
...für eine lokale Anwendung schon mal...
...mit irgendeinem dämlichen Account anmelden muss...
...da habe ich schon mal wieder keinen Bock drauf.
Das fuckt mich generell so ab...
...dass...
...du für jeden Scheiß...
...mittlerweile ein Login brauchst.
Für jeden Scheiß. Man muss sich das mal vorstellen.
Jetzt seriously...
...bist du Apple-Fan? Nee, würde ich nicht...
...unbedingt sagen. Ich habe einige Apple-Produkte...
...aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich wirklich...
...Apple-Fan bin.
Also ein Ding...
...was mich auch extrem triggert ist...
...wenn man diese Geforce Experience...
...aufmachen will, also quasi die Settings...
...für die Grafikkarte...
...das zweite Settings-Menü...
...für die Grafikkarte, muss man sich ja auch schon seit...
...ernsthaft?
Ernsthaft?
Muss man sich ja auch schon seit Jahren einloggen...
...wo ich mir so denke, Alter...
...warum muss ich für fucking lokale Settings...
...für meine Grafikkarte einen Account erstellen?
Das ist echt so ein Trend...
...seit Jahren schon...
...das ist eigentlich eines der Trends...
...gerade auch im Desktop-Bereich so...
...Usability-Bereich...
...der mich mit am meisten abpackt.
Dieses für jeden Scheiß...
...irgendwo einen Account anlegen.
Ja...
...ja, was da auch toll ist...
...ich hab ja...
...ich mach mal kurz meine VM an...
...ich habe ja...
...WLAN-Access-Points von Ruckus...
...und die...
...sind der Meinung...
...wenn man sich...
...äh...was ist das?
...was ist mit meiner VM?
Cannot open C-Doppel-User-Streams...
...VMs-Stream...
...und die anderen gehen?
...die anderen gehen...
...okay...
...Moment, das müssen wir jetzt mal kurz gucken...
...Stream...
...VMs...
...ja...
...Stream...ach hier, die ganzen Logs...
...müssen weg wahrscheinlich...
...das ist ein Bug von VMware...
...den gibt es manchmal...
...man weiß nicht so genau warum...
...guck, zack, geht wieder...
...keine Ahnung, das ist ein Bug...
...den gibt es manchmal...
...keine Ahnung, was es damit auf sich hat...
...so...
...jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich nachgucken wollte, Leute...
...anmelden...
...Jetki, jetzt habe ich vergessen, ich wollte euch irgendwas...
...ach ja, genau, ich habe WLAN-Access-Points...
...jetzt weiß ich es wieder...
...ich habe WLAN-Access-Points, so und jetzt...
...zum Beispiel hier...
...R710-Firmware...
...da kommt man beim...
...da kommt man beim Hersteller raus von dem WLAN-Access-Point...
...und wenn man jetzt sagt, okay...
...ich möchte mir die neueste Firmware runterladen, beziehungsweise...
...ich möchte die Release-Notes...
...lesen, also erstmal...
...findet man auf der Webseite schon mal gar nichts richtig...
...really sucked...
...extremely sucked...
...wenn man jetzt hier auf Downloads geht...
...sich die letzte...
...die letzte Firmware-Version raussucht, da muss man auch ganz genau...
...wissen, nach was man sucht...
...und...
...gab es erst gestern...
...gab es erst gestern ein neues Release, muss ich mir mal nachher die Change-Log...
...Change-Log durchlesen, so und wenn man jetzt sagt, okay...
...ich will Firmware runterladen für meinen Access-Point...
...mich interessiert allerdings...
...die Release-Notes...
...dann klickst du die Release-Notes an...
...und sagst, aha hier, Download-Document...
...oder überhaupt lesen...
...und dann kommt, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein...
...sie müssen sich erstmal anmelden...
...wenn ich Glück habe, habe ich hier...
...irgendeinen Fake-Account und kann mich damit anmelden...
...und nice...
...mein Fake-Account funktioniert noch...
...und jetzt kann man sich das durchlesen...
...warum brauche ich für das Lesen...
...von einem Firmware-Change-Log...
...überhaupt ein Login...
...was haben sie denn...
...was haben sie denn gefixt hier...
...New in this Release...
...OFDL...
...okay, brauche ich nicht...
...nichts was mich interessiert...
...UI Enhance...
...Enhancement...na gut...
...das ist auch so ein Ding, wo es mich wahnsinnig nervt...
...dass man sich da überhaupt einloggen muss für...
...vielleicht, aber...
...was wäre das Problem...
...die Change-Logs von der Firmware...
...crawlen...
...sehe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt...
...kein...
...großartiges Problem drin...
...ja, siehste...
...wie gesagt, das ist dort genauso...
...und das ist in vielen Bereichen so...
...kennt jemand noch, wo wir gerade dabei sind...
...kennt noch jemand die alte...
...ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt mittlerweile anders aussieht...
...ähm...
...kennt noch jemand die alte IBM-Support-Webseite...
...die...
...verwirrendste, hässlichste...
...und langsamste...
...unfunktionalste Webseite...
...die es je gegeben hat...
...wie man hier gerade sieht beim Laden...
...wie ihr...
...wie ihr hier vielleicht feststellt...
...okay...
...die Seite sieht moderner aus mittlerweile...
...ob sie wirklich moderner ist...
...weiß ich nicht...
...aber...
...sie sieht zumindest einen Tick moderner aus...
...aber habt ihr gesehen, wie wahnsinnig schnell...
...diese Webseite gewesen ist...
...guckt euch das mal an...
...ah gut, jetzt funktioniert's...
...okay, nee, die haben die Seite geupdatet...
...die haben die Seite geupdatet...
...release date 2007...
...ja, beste...
...öffnen kannst du das jetzt gar nicht...
...error loading page...
...FTP...
...
...da weißt du, 2007...
...hat angerufen...
...erst mal Filezilla installieren...
...hast du nicht...
...die Azure Experience genießen dürfen...
...doch...
...aber da fällt mir jetzt nichts ein...
...was auch irgendwie close...
...von der Bedienbarkeit...
...der Langsamkeit...
...und der Nichtfunktionalität der alten IBM Webseite...
...hinkommt...
...ich finde ganz ehrlich, von allen großen Cloudern...
...wobei ich sagen muss, mit AWS habe ich persönlich auch wenig gemacht...
...ich finde eigentlich immer noch...
...dass Azure das beste Web...
...zumindest Webinterface das beste hat...
...Google geht mittlerweile auch ganz gut...
...klar...
...bei AWS ist das einzige was ich von weiß...
...dass die Benamung halt ziemlich dämlich ist...
...aber...
...da muss man wohl durch...
...ich finde Azure nicht verkehrt...
...ich habe jahrelang im Azure Webinterface...
...rum klickern müssen...
...ja, dieses zweigeteilte Menü...
...auf der linken Seite zum ausklappen...
...das ist dann alles nicht so dolle...
...aber ich finde es geht ganz gut...
...außerdem ist die Suche, finde ich, in Azure ganz brauchbar...
...bei Google ist es zum Beispiel...
...ein bisschen doof...
...dass du nicht gescheit...
...also habe ich öfters Probleme mit...
...deswegen weiß ich das jetzt, dass du nicht...
...IP-Adressen suchen kannst...
...schon gar nicht, wenn sie projektübergreifend sind...
...was ein bisschen doof ist...
...in Webinterface...
...was aber auch nicht weiter schlimm ist...
...weil ich das mit dem CLI-Tool machen kann...
...so Arch, by the way...
...wenn wir die Kiste schon mal anhaben...
...einmal updaten...
...jawohl...
...OpenJPG...
...und WIM...
...ich bin ja froh, dass das WIM-Development weitergeht...
...obwohl der WIM-Erfinder...
...letztens gestorben ist...
...glücklicherweise ist das...
...eines der großen Vorteile...
...von einem ordentlich organisierten Open-Source-Projekt...
...und die letzten Jahre über...
...hat sich ja WIM da ordentlich gewandelt...
...das war ja jahrzehntelang so eine One-Man-Show...
...Neo-WIM-Stream...
...ja...
...ich weiß...
...steht immer noch an...
...jetzt können wir die VM...
...eigentlich...
...eigentlich wieder ausschalten...
...weil wir brauchen sie heute nicht...
...auf der anderen Seite, ich lass sie einfach mal an...
...weil ich will ja öfters mal irgendwelche Sachen zeigen...
...du nimmst nur Nano...
...Nano ist für Noobs...
...coole Leute...
...nehmen gar keinen grafischen Editor...
...wir machen alles mit Z...
...alles andere ist bloated...
...und eigentlich ist Z schon bloated...
...direkt inline...
...Hex-Editor...
...hast du das mit der Terraform-Lizenz mitbekommen?
...ja, hab ich mitbekommen...
...und ich hab da in den letzten Streams schon was drüber gesagt...
...also...
...im Großen und Ganzen kann ich die super Aufregung...
...gerade nicht nachvollziehen, weil...
...selbst wenn das neue Terraform...
...also die Supporten, die Open-Source...
...also die richtige Open-Source-Version...
...aber...
...selbst wenn...
...das kommt, so wie es geplant ist...
...und da geh ich mal von aus...
...es ändert sich ja nichts großartig...
...du kannst Terraform weiter benutzen...
...du kannst dir den Source-Code von Terraform angucken...
...was du nicht machen kannst...
...ist mit Terraform ein Terraform-Konkurrenz-Produkt erstellen...
...was streng genommen dazu führt...
...dass Terraform keine Open-Source...
...kein Open-Source-Projekt mehr ist...
...nach den Vorgaben der...
...wie heißen die...
...Free-Software-Open-Source-Foundation oder sowas...
...ja, ok...
...aber ganz ehrlich, den Weltuntergang...
...sehe ich da noch nicht...
...zumindest nicht so sehr, wie das teilweise auf Reddit...
...und in...
...Informatikurskreisen abgegangen ist...
...also da wird wieder...
...ziemlich viel herbeigeredet...
...was wahrscheinlich gar nicht so kommen wird...
...und ob da Terraform-Fork...
...oder ein Terraform-Fork...
...da...
...Fahrt aufnimmt...
...ich wage es zu bezweifeln...
...oder...
...was denkst du dazu?
...oder was denkt ihr dazu?
...ich glaube, die Aufregung ist es nicht wert...
...ich bin mal gespannt, was bei mir auf der Arbeit passiert...
...wir benutzen Terraform für relativ viel...
...ob dort auch irgendwie...
...einer kalte Füße kriegt und denkt...
...wir müssen jetzt was anderes benutzen, wo du wirklich keine Ahnung hast...
...wie es sich in Zukunft entwickelt...
...wir können ja mal kurz gucken hier...
...ich habe das seit ein paar Tagen nicht mehr angeguckt...
...Open Terraform...
...das Open Terraform Manifesto...
...ja da geht es schon los mit...
...ja...
...wo ist das Github?
...ja ok...
...also außer irgendwie...
...großspurige Texte...
...gibt es da noch nichts...
...sie haben erst den Fork announced von Terraform...
...aber auf der anderen Seite...
...ich muss euch ehrlich sagen...
...ich hätte auch gar kein Problem...
...gar kein Problem damit...
...wenn das einer forkt...
...und das...
...erfolgreich...
...wenn das ein bisschen Traction aufnimmt...
...wenn das ein bisschen Fahrt aufnimmt...
...und wenn es dort vielleicht auch ein bisschen...
...weniger zentral gesteuerte...
...Sachen gibt...
...und wenn es unterm Strich zu einem...
...guten Produkt...
...vielleicht sogar besserem Terraform führt...
...bin ich da voll dafür...
...ja...
...ich kann die Beweggründe auch tatsächlich...
...irgendwo nachvollziehen...
...aber es ist ja nicht so als wäre es jetzt...
...für den größten Teil der Anwender...
...von Terraform jetzt mit der Lizenzänderung...
...irgendwie komplett unbenutzbar geworden...
...ich denke nicht...
...dass beides damit in irgendeiner Art...
...ok Cloudpreise...
...aber Cloudpreise sind ja unabhängig von der Terraform Lizenz...
...und das GitLab und Terraform Integration...
...ich glaube da wird sich nichts dran ändern...
...richtig...genau...
...sag ich ja...
...das sind wahrscheinlich noch zu wenig...
...das betrifft die allermeisten nicht...
...du kannst ja im Prinzip bloß nicht hergehen...
...und sagen...
...ich biete dir jetzt eine...
...Infrastructure as Code...
...
...Plattform an...
...oder...
...wir können das ja mal besonders buzzwordmäßig machen...
...ich biete eine IAXAS Plattform an...
...
...was technisch genommen sogar nicht der korrekte Ausdruck...
...dafür wäre...
...eine IAXAS Plattform an...
...in Konkurrenz zur Terraform Cloud...
...das könnte ich nicht machen...
...und das auf Terraform Basis...
...eine IAXAS...ja...
...das sind die Auswüchse von...
...immer mehr Abkürzungen...also...
...was ich meine ist...
...IAXAS...
...genau...
...Infrastructure as Code...
...Software as a Service...
...das ist halt...würdest du...
...also Terraform Cloud ist ja eine IAXAS...
...das ist eine...
...Infrastructure as Code...
...Service as a Platform...
...ne das glaube ich nicht...
...dass sich da was tut...
...und sollte...
...dann hoffe ich wirklich...
...dass der Terraform Fork gut abgeht...
...ich meine...
...die haben ja immerhin...
...die haben ja tatsächlich doch...
...einiges an Zuspruch gefunden...
...wenn du dir das hier mal anguckst...
...der Terraform...
...mit der Terraform wir sind nicht zufrieden...
...damit Text...
...der hat 32.000 Github Sterne...
...nicht dass in dem Repo...
...irgendwas Handfestes zu finden wäre...
...außer halt den Text...
...bzw. den Source Code...
...von dem Account.js...
...ja...
...ich bin mal gespannt...
...ich bin mal gespannt was da rauskommt...
...also ich sehe nicht den akuten Weltuntergang...
...aller Terraform Anwender...
...aber mal schauen...ich meine...
...letztendlich wie sagt man so schön...
...Konkurrenz belebt das Geschäft...
...und wenn HashiCorp da ein bisschen...
...Konkurrenz hat...
...bekommt quasi aus...
...mehr oder weniger mit ihrem eigenen Produkt...
...dadurch dass sie ihr eigenes Produkt...
...ein bisschen einschränken wollten...
...warum nicht...ich meine am Endeffekt...
...wird es für uns unterm Strich...
...wahrscheinlich sogar nur von Vorteil sein...
...sollte es dort was geben...
...ich würde mal fast sagen...
...HashiCorp hat einige...
...größere Cloud Produkte...
...aber Terraform dürfte denke ich mal...
...mit das Bedeutende sein...
...die haben Vault...was hat HashiCorp alles...
...die haben Vault...früher hatten die noch...
...Vacrant...Terraform...
...Konsul...
...was haben die sonst noch so...
...muss mal gucken...
...HashiCorp...
...Terrapacker...Vault...Boundary...
...noch nie verwendet...Konsul...Nomad...
...Waypoint noch nie verwendet...Vacrant...
...Vacrant das ist noch...richtig oldschool...
...Virtualbox Automatisierung...
...in...wisst ihr...
...in welcher Programmiersprache...Vacrant...
...programmiert ist...
...äh...
...es ist programmiert in Ruby...
...und das ist...
...das älteste Produkt von denen...
...das gibt es schon bevor es HashiCorp gab...
...damit ging alles los im Endeffekt...
...ja...
...aber ich würde tatsächlich sagen...
...Terraform...
...und Vault...
...aber vorne Terraform...
...ist tatsächlich...würde ich persönlich sagen...
...ist das...
...bedeutendste und bekannteste aktuell...
...von denen...
...ich...ich hab hier so ne...
...so ne Hassbeziehung...irgendwie so...
...Hass-Liebe-Beziehung...
...zu Terraform...
...ich finde es...nice...also ich finde...
...diese Produktkategorie an sich...
...sehr sinnvoll...ja...dass es sowas gibt...
...ich finde auch...
...von den Features her...und gerade eben...
...weil der Standard schlechthin ist...und es alles irgendwie für Terraform gibt...
...finde ich Terraform nice...
...was ich überhaupt...
...gar nicht mag...ist Terraform an sich...
...wie man dort...
...Module anlegt...
...wie man Variablen definiert...
...wie umständlich man Kontrollfluss...
...machend macht...
...ich meine man muss sich ja nur mal die Schleife angucken...
...dann diese Inline-Loop-Syntax...
...dann das Templaten...
...was nicht gescheit funktioniert...also ganz ehrlich...
...ich finde die Produktkategorie cool...
...und ja...das drumherum...
...das Ökosystem was Terraform mitbringt...
...was ich überhaupt nicht mag...ist Terraform selbst...
...ich krieg da regelmäßig...ich muss auf der Arbeit...
...grad relativ viel Terraform bauen...
...ich bin da jedes Mal am kotzen...
...wenn ich feststelle wie kompliziert manches in Terraform ist...
...was eigentlich nicht kompliziert sein müsste...
...beziehungsweise wie undurchsichtig es ist...
...überhaupt rauszufinden...
...ich wollte letztens...
...nur mal so...
...man würde ja von ausgehen...
...stellt euch mal vor...
...ich zeige euch mal...
...für Leute die das...
...so...
...ich zeige euch erstmal das...für Leute...
...die das noch nicht gesehen haben...was das ist...
...was...ah...
...ich muss euch das übrigens gar nicht zeigen...
...ich kann das bei euch bei mir auf GitHub zeigen...
...äh...
...gut dass ich meine 4M anhab...
...wo hab ich denn meinen Terraform-Krempel...
...auf GitHub...
...bestimmt im...
...PQS-Service ist ein bisschen Terraform...
...hier Terraform...
...ja...also was man damit macht...
...äh...Antikrümel...danke für den Sub...
...was man mit Terraform macht ist...
...man legt Ressourcen...
...bei Cloud-Providern an...
...es muss jetzt nicht Google, Amazon...
...oder Microsoft sein...
...es kann auch Hetzner sein oder sowas...
...Terraform unterstützt halt mehr oder weniger...
...fast alles was es gibt...
...da machst du dann zum Beispiel solche Sachen hier...
...nehmen wir mal einfach das hier als Beispiel...
...ist relativ simpel...da sagst du hier...
...ich möchte in dem Fall...
...ein Google Compute Network anlegen...
...mit dem und den Parametern...
...hups...mit dem und den Parametern...
...äh...interne IP-Range...
...soll das hier verwendet werden...
...secondary IP-Range das und das und das...
...also so sieht das aus...
...also sprich man definiert seine Infrastruktur...
...als Source-Code...
...das ist ja im Prinzip das wofür IAC auch steht...
...Infrastructure as Code...
...man hat so eine Markup-Language...
...in der definiert man...
...wie die Infrastruktur aussehen soll die man erstellen will...
...und dann kann man die...
...ja hat man zum Beispiel noch irgendwelche NAT-Regeln...
...dass die Cloud-Kisten ins Internet kommen...
...dann kann man hier zum Beispiel...so erstellt man eine VM bei Google...
...mit Terraform...das ist so das Minimal-Ding...
...ja man möchte eine VM erstellen...
...vom Maschinentyp E2-Micro...
...das sind so die billigsten VMs bei Google die es gibt...
...Hostname...
...ähm...welches Image man verwenden möchte...
...dann welches Netzwerk angeschlossen werden soll...
...und dass er nicht ausflippen soll...
...wenn sich SSH-Keys ändern...
...so sieht das...ich glaube das ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes Beispiel...
...wofür Terraform da ist...
...was hat das für Vorteile im Vergleich zu von Hand...
...im Web-Interface zusammen klicken...
...naja...es ist schneller...
...es ist nachvollziehbarer...
...und du kannst nichts vergessen...
...dazu kommt...das Terraform selbst...
...den State-Tracked...also...
...sagen wir mal...ich hab definiert dass diese VM...
...den Hostnamen Jump haben soll...
...wenn jetzt irgendjemand hingeht...
...ins Web-Interface geht...
...und das Ding umbenennt in...
...900 IQ...
...und das heißt nicht mehr Jump...
...und das nächste mal läuft Terraform...
...dann stellt Terraform fest...
...dass sich der Hostname außerhalb von Terraform geändert hat...
...und ändert ihn wieder zurück...
...also Terraform hat auch State-Tracking...
...und dementsprechend daraus resultiert...
...dass du mit Terraform...
...was du erstellt hast...auch wieder...
...ich sag mal...mehr oder weniger...
...rückstandslos entfernen kannst...
...du kannst also mit Terraform in der Theorie...
...ziemlich schnell...
...eine Infrastruktur in der Cloud hinstellen...
...wenn du deine Software testen willst zum Beispiel...
...wenn du irgendwas ausprobieren willst...
...auch mehrfach parallel nebeneinander...
...zackig...hinstellen...
...ausprobieren...wieder abreißen...
...genau dafür ist Terraform...
...wenn man da ein bisschen...
...Cloud-Native-Buzzword-Bingo einbauen will...
...dann würde man sagen...
...Terraform ist Teil...
...wie nennen sie das...
...da gab es so einen blöden Artikel...
...genau...
...Terraform unterstützt das...
...Cattle vs. Pets-Konzept...
...ich frag mich...
...wer sich diesen Scheiß immer ausdenkt...
...Alter...
...habt ihr das auch schon mal gehört...
...Cattle vs. Pets-Konzept...
...klingt unglaublich neblig...
...ich weiß...
...aber generell in der Cloud...
...im Cloud-Umfeld wird viel mit solchen tollen...
...Begriffen und Wörtern um sich geschmissen...
...also was damit gemeint ist...
...man soll...
...seine Infrastruktur...
...mehr...
...nicht so sehr wie Pets, nicht so sehr wie Haustiere sehen...
...sondern mehr wie...
...was ist Cattle? Nutzvieh?
...was heißt...
...wie?
...also man soll seine Infrastruktur weniger als...
...so wie Haustiere pflegen...
...sondern eher als Nutztiere sehen...
...die man halt auch mal schlachten kann...
...das ist so die Analogie...
...die sich da irgendjemand ausgedacht hat...
...ja und das...
...das ist so im Groben...
...wofür Terraform da ist...
...also dass man seine...
...Infrastruktur...wir könnten das anders...
...umschreiben, dass man seine Infrastruktur hochzieht...
...und auch wieder regelmäßig wegschmeißen kann...
...ohne dass was groß passiert...
...kaputt geht...so und...
...und so ein Ding...was mich halt...
...was man ja hier sieht...
...eigentlich sieht es relativ simpel aus...
...ne Leute...also weiß ich...
...wer von euch hat noch nie was mit Terraform gemacht...
...aber sagt hey...
...prinzipiell wenn ich mir das hier angucke...
...versteht man eigentlich ganz gut was passiert...
...also ich denke schon oder...
...Maschinetype...
...also es ist glaube ich relativ klar was passiert...
...also das ist tatsächlich...
...ja noch ist das lesbar...
...weil das ein relativ einfacher Fall ist...
...so das ist tatsächlich auch eines der...
...großen Pluspunkte von Terraform...
...dass jetzt auch nicht Programmierer das benutzen können...
...aber Terraform...
...oftmals ist es halt so...
...dass eine Infrastruktur...
...nicht so simpel bleibt...
...wie hier legt man eine VM an...
...zum Beispiel könnte es jetzt sein...
...dass man sagt...
...je nach...
...Entwicklungsstage...
...möchte man unterschiedlich viele VMs haben...
...sagen wir mal...
...für ein Entwicklungssetup reicht dir eine VM...
...für ein live produktives Setup...
...möchtest du 4 VMs haben...
...so was machst du jetzt...
...also du willst dann Jump 1,2,3,4 haben...
...du könntest jetzt diesen Block 4 mal kopieren...
...oder du machst eine Schleife...
...und da sind wir schon beim ersten...
...was etwas gewöhnungsbedürftig ist...
...wie man in Terraform Schleifen macht...
...so weil in Terraform gibt es...
...Count...
...und es gibt For Each...
...in der Regel willst du For Each...
...und es gibt auch Inline Template Schleifen...
...da geht es dann schon los...
...wo es anfängt...
...viele Leute etwas zu...
...zu verwirren...
...also in Wirklichkeit...
...ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz anhand von einem Beispiel...
...wie man das machen würde...
...ich kopiere mir das einfach hier einmal...
...in Visual Studio Code...
...jag mal kurz ein, dass es Terraform ist...
...also normalerweise...
...würdest du das so machen...
...wenn man jetzt diese VM...
...4 mal erstellen möchte...
...sagen wir mal für ein produktives...
...Environment...
...man könnte ja hergehen...
...und das hier dann beispielsweise...
...man könnte das hier kopieren...
...und könnte dann sagen...
...das ist 2 und das ist 1...
...das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof...
...das dupliziert sinnloserweise Code...
...man kann auch sagen...
...For Each...
...so...
...und dann z.B. Count...
...oder man könnte sagen...
...und jetzt kommt es...
...man würde jetzt sagen...
...1,2,3,4 das funktioniert...
...das ist natürlich keine gültige Terraform Syntax...
...dafür...
...das wäre zu einfach wahrscheinlich...
...das ist keine gültige...
...aber mal angenommen das würde funktionieren...
...dann könnte man jetzt z.B. hier sowas sagen...
...Name...
...Each Value...
...so und dann sieht man schon...
...das ist abartig...
...weil...
...For Each ist quasi innerhalb der Ressource...
...ich finde das syntaktisch...
...unglaublich eklig...
...was ich persönlich viel schöner finden würde...
...wenn man sowas machen könnte...
...sowas hier in der Richtung z.B.
...ja...
...ich mache jetzt mal so symbolisch...
...so irgendwie...
...aber das geht in Terraform nicht...
...weil das eben syntaktisch nicht vorgesehen ist...
...das sind Eigenheiten an die man sich gewöhnen muss...
...aber ich meine...
...das geht noch irgendwie...
...leider sobald du solche Sachen machen musst...
...und das dann auch ein bisschen komplizierter wird...
...artet Terraform leider ein bisschen aus...
...weil z.B.
...For Each...
...so mal angenommen...
...ich bekomme jetzt irgendwo ein Input her...
...genauso ein Fall hatte ich nämlich...
...aktuell auf der Arbeit...
...ich möchte Ressourcen...
...ich möchte dort keine VMs anlegen...
...ich nehme das ja nur als Beispiel...
...ich möchte Ressourcen anlegen die...
...fortlaufende Nummern haben...
...die allerdings nicht bei 1 anfangen...
...sondern bei...
...sagen wir mal...
...10 bis 25...
...bleiben wir mal so...
...und dann gibt es bei Terraform sowas...das nennt sich Range...
...man würde davon ausgehen...
...man könnte sowas machen...Range...
...11 bis 30 z.B.
...klingt logisch...klingt nachvollziehbar...
...würde man eigentlich erwarten...
...funktioniert oder?
...irgendwie...findet ihr nicht auch...
...das sieht syntaktisch so aus...
...wie etwas was funktionieren sollte...
...und dann könnte ich an der Stelle sagen...
...Each...
...Key oder Each Value oder sowas...
...klingt syntaktisch...
...finde ich schön wenn das funktioniert...
...funktioniert aber nicht...
...ist nicht möglich in Terraform sowas zu machen...
...in Terraform muss man...
...damit das funktioniert...
...muss man sowas hier machen...
...ich hoffe ich kriege das jetzt überhaupt irgendwie hin...
...man muss erstmal ein Array erzeugen...
...da drin sagt man Range...
...und Range...
...ergibt Integers aus...
...Integers kann man in For Each...
...aus welchen Gründen auch immer nicht verwenden...
...deswegen muss man sowas hier sagen...
...For Each in Range...
...Doppelpunkt...
...ähm...tja...
...E...ne Moment...
...ähm...
...String Template...
...E...
...so...und dann hat man...
...eine...
...eine String Liste mit...
...Ints als String...
...weil Ints in For Each selbst nicht unterstützt werden...
...For Each selber unterstützt aber gar keine Listen...
...deswegen muss ich sagen...
...To Set...
...drumherum...
...und das sind so Dinger, ihr könnt euch vorstellen, der Shit artet unglaublich schnell aus...
...und ist hässlich as fuck...
...so...
...es gibt natürlich noch eine andere Möglichkeit das zu machen...
...man könnte das hier auch weglassen...
...man könnte gleich sagen...
...man erzeugt ein Set...
...damit man in Terraform ein Set erzeugen kann...
...braucht man aber ein Key-Value Pair...
...und jetzt würde ich ein Key-Value Pair erzeugen...
...was als Key und Value das gleiche hat...
...also Leute...
...Pepega-Shit...
...richtig, richtig Pepega-Shit...
...und das sind so Dinger...
...die...
...regen mich ein bisschen an Terraform auf...
...und glaubt mir Leute...
...das artet total aus mit der Zeit...
...ähm...
...ich persönlich finde das hier vom Ansatz her...
...eigentlich ganz cool...
...denn es gibt quasi so eine...
...so eine Art Erweiterung von Terraform...
...CDK, TF...
...das war ursprünglich AWS-only...
...mittlerweile ist das für alle Cloud-Anbieter...
...möglich...
...da kannst du Terraform...
...in einer normalen...
...Programmiersprache schreiben...
...kannst du TypeScript, Python, Java, C-Sharp...
...Go und so verwenden...
...das finde ich persönlich sehr viel angenehmer...
...erinnert mich ein bisschen an Pulumi...
...leider ist da so die Adoption...
...im Enterprise-Sektor noch recht...
...gering...
...was ich doof finde...
...ja...
...weil zum Beispiel...
...machen wir irgendwie mal...
...ein C-Sharp-Example...
...weil zum Beispiel...
...könnte ich dann sowas hier schreiben...
...in einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache, ja...
...könnte ich dann sagen, hier...
...Google Cloud Provider, Compute Instance...
...und ihr habt recht...
...wenn ihr jetzt sagen würdet, hey Max...
...ich finde das hier aber deutlich lesbarer...
...ja, das ist auch erstmal...
...so reines Markup ist auch erstmal...
...deutlich besser lesbar, als wenn man das...
...in einer Programmiersprache erstellt, aber...
...sobald, und ihr habt es eben gesehen...
...sobald...
...irgendwie ein bisschen Logik dazukommt...
...ist das einfach deutlich überlegen...
...du hast halt kompletten Zugriff...
...auf die Standard Library der Sprache...
...du kannst ordentliche Logik...
...Auswertungen machen da drinne...
...ja...
...deswegen fand ich auch...
...Pulumi immer angenehmer...
...als Terraform...
...aber das hat sich...
...also Terraform hat sich einfach...
...durchgesetzt...
...ja, so sieht das aus...
...getting started, wir müssen uns das bei Gelegenheit...
...übrigens mal angucken...
...was fällt denn da unten drunter eigentlich raus...
...ein komplett gültiges Terraform Modul...
...oder...
...hat sich damit jemand schonmal beschäftigt...
...kann man damit...
...Terraform Module erstellen...
...vom CDK...
...äh, CDK TF...
...das wäre natürlich sehr nice...
...weil dann braucht man das nur klein-
...seitig...
...und den Rest kann man knicken...
...das muss ich...Leute, ich würde sagen...
...ich würde sagen...
...das müssen wir uns mal ein bisschen...
...näher angucken...
...gut...
...soweit, so gut, kleiner Exkurs...
...Richtung...
...Cloud-Infrastruktur...
...ich verdiene ja da mein Geld mit...
...muss ich ab und zu wenigstens so tun, als...
...weiß ich, was ich mache...
...Anti-Krümel-POG-Subscription...
...habe ich glaube ich schon dreimal erzählt jetzt, aber...
...trotzdem...
...ist das sowas wie Docker für Datacenter?
...nee...
...nee, nicht wirklich...
...du kannst damit jegliche Cloud-Infrastruktur anlegen...
...du kannst auch Projekte...
...Google-Projekte anlegen in der Cloud...
...und da drinnen dann irgendwelche Google-Services...
...konfigurieren, Pub-Sub, was auch immer...
...nee, kann man nicht wirklich...
...das hat mit Container und Images nichts zu tun...
...du kannst damit unter anderem VMs anlegen, aber so ziemlich alles...
...was die jeweiligen Cloud-Anbieter anbieten...
...da du mal gesagt hast...
...dass du kein richtiges Argument...
...gegen eine Linux-VM auf Windows gehört hast...
...um Windows und Linux zu vereinen...
...habe ich zwei Argumente...
...erstens, wenn ich auf Linux produktiv bin...
...ist die Verlockung auf Windows zu zocken kleiner...
...wenn ich erstmal zu wuten muss...
...und das zweite Argument hier in Form...
...eines guten Memes...
...ich kann das auf Windows machen...
...he, he...
...ja...gut...
...das erste...das verstehe ich, ja...
...das ist aber nur gültig...
...solange du vor hast...
...dich etwas zu zügeln...
...was deinen Spielgenuss angeht...
...das ist ja bei mir überhaupt nicht der Fall...
...ich will mich ja gar nicht zurückhalten...
...was Spiel angeht...
...ich spiele eh schon nicht...
...im Vergleich zu früher viel...
...ab und zu wenn mal so ein Game wie...
...ja, das mit den Windows Updates ist nervig...
...aber nicht das du trotz...
...machst du halt...
...trotzdem noch einige Sachen unter Windows besser...
...als unter Linux und da bleibt dir dann auch nichts übrig...
...als zu wuten...
...und wenn du Windows als dein Hauptbetriebssystem hast...
...dann musst du auch nicht Updates installieren...
...wenn du gerade bootest...
...sondern du hast die Updates halt irgendwann mal beim Shutdown installiert...
...dann geht's...
...aber ja, Windows Updates, die forciert einem aufs Auge gedrückt werden...
...geht mir auch auf den Sack...
...Hallo, hat man dann ein Array von VMs...
...für die der Traffic gesplittet wird...
...wie kann man sich das als NOOB vorstellen...
...nein, hat man nicht, man hat 4 verschiedene VMs...
...also wenn du das hier benutzt, was ich dir gerade gezeigt habe...
...das da, ja...
...also mal angenommen, du würdest jetzt damit 4 VMs anlegen...
...so wie ich das hier gezeigt habe...
...4 each gleich...
...ja, es ist Terraform, du müsstest hier sowas machen, dass das funktioniert...
...weil...
...weil Terraform, ja...
...und ich glaube, du müsstest sogar noch...
...du müsstest sogar noch sowas hier machen, dass das funktioniert...
...so...
...und dann würdest du hier sagen, war mal underscore...
...each value...
...so, jetzt würdest du, wenn du das ausfüllst...
...kriegst du 4 VMs...
...das bedeutet nicht, dass da irgendwie...
...der Traffic zwischen den 4 VMs gesplittet wird...
...das musst du schon noch anlegen...
...hier hast du erstmal nur 4 VMs...
...du hast übrigens nur 4 VMs...
...mit nacktem Debian drauf...
...sonst gar nichts...
...4 VMs mit einer frischen Debian-Installation...
...die an diesem Netzwerk...
...die in diesem Netzwerk hängen...
...das ist alles, mehr hast du nicht...
...da wird kein Traffic gesplittet oder nichts...
...wenn du willst, dass Traffic gesplittet wird...
...da musst du sowas hier machen, zum Beispiel...
...na gut, das ist jetzt ein doofes Beispiel...
...da musst du Netzwerkgeräte anlegen in der Cloud...
...oder virtuelle Netzwerkgeräte in der Cloud anlegen...
...z.B. Cloud-Load-Balancer anlegen...
...die den Traffic splitten...
...das kannst du auch machen über Terraform...
...ja, du könntest über Terraform...
...dann könntest du z.B. bei Google...
...ein Application-Load-Balancer anlegen...
...das sieht dann so aus...
...in der Richtung, guck...
...das da oben kannst du vergessen...
...das kannst du auch ignorieren...
...ja, du kannst hier Ressource...
...GCE-LB für HTTP...
...kannst du anlegen...
...ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt so funktioniert...
...und dann würdest du einstellen...
...als meine Backends möchte ich...
...auf diese VMs eben Load-Balancen...
...da sagst du hier Instance-Group...
...das sind dann unter der Haube deine VMs...
...kommt noch ein Schritt dazwischen...
...hier sind dann deine VMs drin...
...und dann würdest du sagen, ich will HTTP Port 80...
...Load-Balancen...
...auf diese Instance-Groups...
...was unter der Haube deine VMs wären...
...und du willst sogar noch einen Health-Check machen...
...ja, so würde das...
...das könntest du mit Terraform auch anlegen...
...aber rein das Erstellen von 4 VMs...
...verteilt noch kein Traffic auf die...
...unterschiedlichen Endpunkte...
...ist ja auch logisch...
...du willst ja auch so viele Sachen vielleicht konfigurieren...
...die gar nicht automatisch...
...wie soll das automatisch gehen...
...du willst ja vielleicht auch dein Traffic gar nicht splitten...
...du willst halt vielleicht einfach wirklich einfach nur 4 VMs haben...
...die miteinander nichts zu tun haben...
...also...
...letztendlich zwingt dich Microsoft ja sogar dazu...
...beim runterfahren...
...nach 1-2 Wochen...
...du musst dann Updates machen...
...ja, so sieht's aus...
...kann man das irgendwie lokal probieren...
...oder muss ich zum Ausprobieren erstmal einen Cloud-Service holen...
...kommt drauf an, was du probieren willst...
...also wenn du jetzt explizit das hier probieren möchtest...
...Google Compute Instance...
...das kannst du natürlich nicht...
...lokal machen...
...wenn du beispielsweise...
...den Kubernetes-Part davon ausprobieren willst...
...das geht, du kannst lokal Minikube starten...
...wobei...
...ganz ehrlich Terraform mit Kubernetes mischen ist so ein Ding...
...würde ich auf jeden Fall mich etwas zurückhalten...
...wie sehr ich beides miteinander...
...also professionieren des Clusters...
...und vielleicht ein paar Default-Sachen setzen...
...ist gut über Terraform...
...danach würde ich mit Terraform nicht weiter...
...mit meinem Cluster rumwürsten...
...aber was du zum Beispiel machen kannst...
...du kannst den Terraform-Libvirt-Provider benutzen...
...und dann kannst du...
...zum Beispiel...
...lokale VMs erzeugen...
...die dann so aussehen...
...guck...
...kannst du KVM-VMs unter Linux anlegen...
...damit...
...Terraform hat jede Menge Provider...
...und Module...
...für so nahezu alles...
...also Registry Terraform...
...das ist quasi die offizielle Package-Manager...
...da kannst du nach allem suchen...
...du kannst auch beispielsweise nach Hetzner suchen...
...und dann wirst du feststellen...
...ach guck mal...
...es gibt sogar offiziell von Hetzner bereitgestellte Terraform-Module...
...für die Hetzner-Cloud...
...da hast du dann solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel...
...Hetzner-Cloud-Loadbalancer...
...kannst du Loadbalancer anlegen...
...oder Hetzner-Cloud-Server...
...da kannst du VMs anlegen...
...also Terraform jeder...
...das ist halt einer der großen Pluspunkte...
...von Terraform...
...eines der großen Pluspunkte von Terraform...
...weil es eben der Standard schlechthin ist...
...für sowas...
...jeder Anbieter...
...der irgendwie...
...ein bisschen erfolgreich sein will...
...also jeder Hosting- oder Service-Anbieter...
...hat ein Terraform-Modul...
...ohne Terraform-Modul musst du dich heute...
...als Anbieter nicht mehr blicken lassen...
...ja...
...gibt sogar eins...
...war das eins und eins?
...Ionos hast du...
...du hast...
...so was wie Gmx...
...wobei das ist ja eine E-Mail...
...eins und eins...
...ja Telekom...
...was hat die Telekom so?
...Telekom-Indonesia...
...also du musst dich als Infrastruktur-Anbieter...
...nicht Magenta...
...ja vielleicht so ein bisschen...
...du kannst DNS und Domains verwalten...
...auch noch mehr...
...MonkaS...
...die Grundrolle...
...du kannst die allermeisten Anbieter...
...über Terraform verwalten...
...ja so sieht es aus...
...aber von der Syntax her...
...ich mag Terraform...
...sobald es ein bisschen komplexer wird einfach nicht...
...gut...
...was gucken wir uns denn jetzt mal an?
...wenn du nicht aufpasst...
...das passt schon...
...das ist mit Terraform natürlich auch besonders einfach...
...viele Cloud-Kosten zu verursachen...
...weil guckt mal...
...stellt euch mal vor...
...so was hier...
...würde funktionieren...
...ich glaube sogar, dass es mehr oder weniger...
...in Terraform so ähnlich funktioniert...
...weiß ich aus dem Kopf gerade nicht...
...wie hier das richtige Syntax für ist...
...so stellt euch mal vor...
...ich hätte jetzt hier nicht...
...E2 Micro...
...E2...
...Google Namen...
...ich habe N...
...2...
...8K...
...32G...
...und jetzt sage ich...
...Count...
...9999...
...das kostet dann halt ein bisschen was...
...wenn die Dinger an sind...
...das ist in Terraform einfach nur...
...eine Zahl ändern...
...also wenn man da nicht aufpasst...
...kann das natürlich ins Geld gehen...
...aber nachdem das immer noch jemand...
...von Hand ändern muss...
...würde ich sagen...
...das Risiko hält sich in Grenzen...
...aber es könnte...
...das lag aber an was anderem...
...das könnte passieren...
...so...
...was können wir uns denn jetzt angucken...
...better than Windows...
...ja...
...das gucken wir uns jetzt an...
...Linux Mint...
...ist bei euch super beliebt...
...wir gucken uns das Betriebssystem...
...mal genauer an...
...wir haben uns Linux Mint auch schon...
...im Stream angeguckt...
...und ich empfehle...
...Linux Mint tatsächlich auch ganz gern...
...wenn jemand im Chat wieder fragt...
...Max was ist eine gute Einsteiger Distribution...
...dann sage ich eigentlich zu 99% der Fälle...
...Arch Linux...
...aber wir sind uns einig dass es Arch Linux ist...
...beste Distribution überhaupt...
...weil Arch Linux btw...
...was ich natürlich auch use...
...und ich euch selbstverständlich...
...wie das sich für einen zünftigen...
...Arch Linux User gehört...
...das ich euch auch erzählen muss...
...öfters mal...
...dass ich btw Arch btw benutze...
...gut...
...dann gucken wir uns das doch mal an...
...was er sagt...
...zu Linux Mint...
...aber mit Arch Install...
...ach...
...ich habe meine Liete schon wieder definiert...
...was zählt und was nicht zählt...
...aber meins ist nur virtualisiert...
...das ist richtig...
...aber was ändert das jetzt...
...außer dass es für mich...
...Usability technisch einfacher ist...
...wo vielleicht der 0-15 Arch User...
...nicht so viel Wert drauf legt...
...ja also wenn du konkret...
...was wissen willst...
...auch wenn wir hier im Stream Themen haben...
...dann schieß los...
...das ist ja hier was dazu da...
...wenn wir Technik Sachen machen...
...heute jetzt nicht unbedingt beim Video gucken...
...erzähle ich ja auch immer von Gott und der Welt...
...aber wenn wir Technik Sachen im Stream machen...
...was ja zu 90% der Fall ist...
...außer wenn ich 3 Wochen am Stück Baldur's Gate spiele...
...dann hat das 2 Gründe...
...hier im Stream so...
...erstens...
...dass ihr vielleicht noch ein bisschen was lernt...
...oder...
...ich habe den Eindruck...
...manche Leute benutzen den Stream...
...nicht unbedingt...
...dafür...
...wie soll ich das sagen...
...also es sind viele Leute da, die lernen was...
...also ich sage jetzt erstmal das was ich ursprünglich sagen wollte...
...also der Stream ist ja unter anderem dafür da...
...dass Leute die zugucken was lernen...
...und dass ich was lerne...ich lerne jeden Stream was...
...wenn ich hier irgendwas bastle...
...durch den Chat...durch Sachen die ich ausprobiere...
...jeden Stream...
...ich habe aber manchmal den Eindruck...
...es gibt ein paar Zuschauer hier im Stream...
...wenn wir Technik Sachen machen...
...die gucken eigentlich nur zu...
...um mir zu erzählen...
...dass sie es besser wissen...
...vielleicht erkennt sich da der ein oder andere...
...wieder...
...genau...genau...die wollen eigentlich...
...nur ein bisschen flexen...
...das kommt natürlich auch öfters mal vor...
...ist aber auch ok...
...ist aber auch ok...also ich habe von Leuten...
...hier im Stream auch schon viel gelernt...
...gerade was CSS angeht...
...da habe ich aus irgendeinem Grund immer den Auskennfuchs...
...im Hinterkopf...als CSS...
...Checker bei uns im Stream...
...der mir immer erklärt hat...
...was die unterschiedlichen Einheiten...
...bei CSS CRIT bedeuten...
...und ich habe es schon wieder komplett vergessen...
...also wir haben hier schon Leute...wir haben auch Leute...
...die ihr Durchblicken...
...sehr offensiv...
...kommunizieren müssen...
...die dir permanent sagen müssen...
...dass sie durchblicken...
...manchmal erzählst du auch eine Menge halbgares Zeug...
...das kann überhaupt nicht sein...
...wann habe ich jemals halbgares Zeug erzählt...
...das ist genauso wenn als nächstes...
...jemand erzählt...
...dass nicht immer alles first try fehlerfrei...
...funktioniert...das würde nämlich...
...bedeuten wir bräuchten Dokumentation und Tests...
...was nicht sein kann...
...weil...
...es dokumentiert sich selbst...
...und wenn es immer funktioniert brauchen wir auch keine Tests...
...du sagst zum Beispiel...
...dass C++ doof ist...ja damit...
...habe ich ja auch recht...wobei ich nie so...
...ultimativ sage dass C++ doof ist...
...sondern ich sage manchmal kommst du halt an...
...C++ ist doch...
...C++ ist ultimativ doof...
...aber manchmal kommst du halt an C++ nicht vorbei...
...ja...
...das ist auch eine Sache die ich schon oft im Stream gesagt habe...
...dass es immer sinnvoll ist...
...so ein bisschen über den Tellerrand zu gucken...
...dass es sinnig ist als Anwendungsentwickler...
...mal gucken so ein bisschen sich beispielsweise...
...mit Container Image bauen und sowas...
...wie das betrieben wird zu beschäftigen...
...und dass es als Admin auch extrem viel bringt...
...weil man ein bisschen programmieren kann...
...PAP ist toll...ok...
...da kann man sich drüber streiten...ich sage ja immer...
...aber realistisch...
...realistisch betrachtet habe ich auch schon...
...Disclaimer...habe ich auch schon oft gesagt...
...man sollte das nehmen...
...was am besten zu dem jeweiligen Projekt passt...
...und wenn man hauptsächlich Leute...
...mit PAP Knowhow hat...
...oder aus irgendwelchen Gründen auf irgendwelchen...
...Legacy Web Hosting Sachen...
...laufen muss...wo nur MySQL...
...und PAP gehen...macht das durchaus Sinn...
...ich mag JavaScript...
...so...
...aber...jetzt gucken wir uns mal an...
...wer dazu Linux Mint erzählt...
...wird das eigentlich Linux Mint ausgesprochen...
...oder gibt es da auch irgendwelche coolen Leute...
...die das...Linux...
...Linux Mind...
...oder so aussprechen müssen...
...oh...Vodafone...
...Vodafone...Vodafone...
...Eff...
...Effke...gehts wieder?
...ich glaube es geht wieder...gell...
...ja...
...Vodafone Man...
...das liegt nicht an deiner Vodafone Leitung...
...das lag an meiner Vodafone Leitung...
...die mal wieder...
...
...Cack Wait gemacht hat...
...also sobald bei mir Glasfaser gelegt wird...
...bin ich sofort am Start...
...ich glaube wir sind halt nicht Top Priorität Ausbau...
...weil es bei uns ja schon theoretisch...
...Kabel Gigabit gibt...
...so...Chatgy...funktioniert bei euch wieder alles...
...alles wieder gut...ja...seid ihr...seid ihr...
...wieder am Start...
...wir resetten mal den Job Frames Counter...
...ok...so...
...dann gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an...ja...um zurück...
...zurück zur Frage zu kommen...
...gibt es auch irgendwelche besonders coolen Aussprache...
...von Linux Mint...
...so dass irgendwelche Leute ankommen mit...
...Linux Mind oder sowas...
...
...also gucken wir mal...
...guck mal hier...das ist Linux Mint...
...und für die Installation auf meinem Windows PC...
...habe ich ernsthaft...
...weniger als 10 Minuten gebraucht...
...ganz ehrlich...guck mal hier...
...das ist Linux Mint...
...und für die Installation auf meinem Windows PC...
...habe ich ernsthaft weniger als 10 Minuten gebraucht...
...ganz ehrlich...die Installation ist bei den meisten...
...Linux Distributionen nicht das Problem...
...das kommt dann danach...
...ich habe noch nie so einen USB Stick...
...außer Arch...
...da ist es schon beim Installieren...
...ein Problem für viele...
...wobei mit Arch Install ist es wirklich easy...
...es ist zwar reinen Text basiert...
...was viele schon mal ein bisschen abschrecken dürfte...
...aber mit Arch Install ist es echt kein Problem mehr...
...einstecken und läuft...
...Linux auf dem Rechner gehabt...
...und jetzt verstehe ich auch so langsam...
...warum ihr da draußen immer schreibt...
...gibt es eigentlich einen neuen...
...Linux Install World Record...
...Arch Install World Record...
...was ist das...
...Arch Linux TAS World Record...
...Tool Assisted...
...Arch Install World Record...
...in Virtual Box...
...Linux...
...Arch...
...Any%...
...gibt es sowas welcher...
...ist Arch schlimmer als Gentoo...
...nein...
...oh...
...Verschreiber...
...FStub von Hand...
...der wartet jetzt oben bis die Install durch ist...
...und dann setzt er das ab...
...muss einer vor allem mehr CPU-Cores geben...
...jawohl...
...ok...
...also...
...Arch Linux Install World Record...
...wir wollen nochmal was zu Linux Mint machen...
...zum Beispiel in dieser Umfrage hier...
...also hier ist es...
...das Video zu Linux Mint...
...was war in der Umfrage drinne...
...Zorin...oh das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen...
...Manjaro ist ja so ein bisschen...
...unbeliebt geworden...
...die letzten Jahre über...
...Jubantu...
...Bothi Vanilla...
...keine Ahnung...
...Jubantu kann man denke ich auch noch ganz gut empfehlen...
...aber ich empfehle auch allen neuen Leuten immer...
...immer Linux Mint...
...und kein...
...Jubantu...
...also hier ist es...
...das Video zu Linux Mint...
...der offenbar bei euch beliebt ist...
...in Linux Geschmacksrichtung...
...Linux Mint habe ich 2 Wochen lang zum Arbeiten benutzt...
...da gab es einiges...
...was ich ziemlich bemerkenswert fand...
...und deshalb gibt es gleich 6 Sachen...
...die mich bei Linux Mint erstaunt haben...
...lieber Eckerin, lieber Internet Server...
...herzlich willkommen hier bei...
...der Sound...
...dieses Video wird gesponsert von...
...Jonas...
...wo wir es gerade von...
...Terraform Providern hatten...
...25 Jahre ist Jonas...
...im Hosting Geschäft unterwegs...
...und der führende deutsche Digitalisierungspartner...
...10 Rechenzentren...
...bringe ich das durcheinander...
...war das nicht 1&1 früher...
...oder war das...
...bringe ich das durcheinander...
...das war 1&1 oder...
...in 5 Ländern...
...mit 100.000 Servern hat Jonas...
...im Einsatz...
...und da findet ihr ziemlich sicher genau das...
...was ihr braucht z.B. in Sachen VPS...
...natürlich auch mit ordentlich GPU Power...
...wenn ihr z.B. KI Anwendungen machen wollt...
...das besondere bei Jonas...
...ihr bekommt 24 7 echten technischen Support...
...mit dedizierten Ansprechpartnern...
...schaut doch mal rein auf www.jonas.de
Werbung Ende
Also ich hab ja schon wirklich...
...viele Linuxe in meinem Leben installiert...
...und das ging auch meistens ganz entspannt...
...aber Linux Mint ist wirklich das erste Linux...
...wo ich während des ganzen Installations...
...und vor allem dem ersten Einschalten Prozess...
...niemals gedacht hab...
...das war jetzt ein bisschen verwirrend...
...warum steht das da jetzt...
...also dieses klassische...
...ja nein...
...ich bin mir nicht sicher...
...ob das ein Meme Bildchen ist...
...aber ich kann mir durchaus...
...genauso einen Dialog vorstellen...
...was ist eigentlich der Unterschied...
...zwischen Arch und Kali...
...das ist ungefähr so...
...wie wenn ich fragen würde...
...was ist der Unterschied zwischen...
...einer Ikea Küche...
...und einer von...
...Müllmax...
...keine Ahnung...
...das sind zwei unterschiedliche Diskussionen...
...mit unterschiedlichem Fokus...
...Kali Linux ist eher so eine...
...out of the box Diskussion...
...für Security Zwecke...
...und Arch Linux ist eher...
...eine Distribution zum Selbst Customizen...
...und so anzupassen...
...wie du willst...
...also...
...ich weiß nicht wie man das sonst...
...gut ich mein Kali selbst...
...ist glaube ich auf Debian Basis...
...aber das macht gerade...
...ja so wie ich gesagt hab...
...NixOS Anton...
...ja das hab ich schon aufgeschrieben...
...Kali ist zum Hacken, Arch zum Flexen...
...ganz gut...
...Arch hat Privacy Fokus...
...Arch ist so Privacy Fokus...
...wie du es machen willst...
...und bei Default ist ja Linux an sich...
...und die Software da drauf schon...
...eigentlich...
...braucht man keine Bedenken zu haben...
...was Privacy angeht...
...wenn man sich...
...Visual Studio Code installiert...
...und dort opt-in...
...oder nicht opt-outet...
...ich weiß gar nicht warum es ist...
...ja das muss man sich dann überlegen...
...man kann natürlich...
...genau man kann natürlich eines der...
...Ent-Micro-Softifizierten...
...Visual Studio Versionen verwenden...
...wobei dann da nicht alles funktioniert...
...wer zum Beispiel Plattform I.O.
...verwenden möchte...
...für Microcontroller...
...hat das Problem, dass die offizielle C++ Extension...
...nur im offiziellen Visual Studio Code...
...läuft...
...ich sag mal lief, weil ich nicht sicher bin...
...ob das noch so ist...
...man kann sich natürlich auch PowerShell...
...und Windows Defender für Linux installieren...
...wenn man da scharf drauf ist...
...aber wer macht sowas...
...also weder Kali...
...noch Arch...
...würde ich da irgendwelche...
...Privacy Sachen problematisch sehen...
...Ubuntu hatte eine Zeit lang...
...im Startmenü solche Geschichten...
...solche Zeigergebnisse von Amazon...
...an und sowas...
...ok, gucken wir uns jetzt das WIT an...
...ich guck jetzt einfach mal ok...
...und checke, was die jetzt von mir wollen...
...bei Linux Mint war das nicht ein einziges Mal so...
...und was ich noch krasser fand...
...ich hab alle für mich wichtigen Tools...
...wie WireGuard, Dropbox, Steam, OBS...
...und so weiter installiert...
...ohne ein einziges Mal eine Kommandozeile zu sehen...
...alles in der grafischen Benutzerverfläche...
...und das ist direkt der erste von 6 Gründen...
...warum Linux Mint erstaunlich ist...
...Grund Nummer 1...
...die Anwendungsverwaltung ist richtig...
...ich muss sagen, was ich an diesen Videos wirklich mag...
...ist das Editing...
...das ist interessant editiert...
...also muss man auch wirklich mal den...
...den Video oder die Video Bearbeiter loben...
...das ist immer interessant editiert...
...aber ohne...
...so ultra krass Zoomer mäßig zu sein...
...also das würde nicht als TikTok Video durchgehen...
...aber es geht als angenehm geschnittenes...
...YouTube Video durch...
...eigentlich würde ich das Ding hier ja App Store nennen...
...aber das ist natürlich genau genommen falsch...
...weil man hier ja gar nichts kaufen kann...
...die Software hier drin ist kostenlos...
...es gibt rein technisch gar keine Kaufmöglichkeiten...
...aber das Programm mit dem etwas sperrigen Namen...
...Anwendungsverwaltung...
...fühlt sich tatsächlich ein bisschen so an...
...wie ein etwas aufgeräumterer App Store...
...bei Apple oder Google...
...was hier oben angezeigt wird...
...ist tatsächlich auch von Menschen kupertiert...
...ein etwas aufgeräumterer...
...ist schön gesagt...
...das bedeutet da ist weniger drin...
...und das sind dann auch wirklich die Programme...
...die viele Leute installieren wollen...
...und nicht die Programme...
...die Leute in einer perfekten Open Source Welt...
...installieren sollten...
...also da finden sich dann halt auch ganz pragmatisch...
...neben so Linux Klassikern wie der Bildbearbeitung GIMP...
...kommerzielle Sachen wie Steam, Spotify...
...oder Microsofts Coding Tool...
...Visual Studio Code...
...eben das was wir heute oft verwenden...
...schöne unbekannte Sachen sind dann direkt darunter...
...nämlich die Programme mit den besten Bewertungen...
...ja wirklich die Anwendungsverwaltung...
...hat echte Bewertungen von echten Menschen...
...die einen auch tatsächlich weiterbringen...
...richtig gut gelöst ist das altbekannte...
...Programm von echten Menschen...
...die einen auch tatsächlich weiterbringen...
...richtig gut gelöst ist das altbekannte Problem...
...wie installiere ich jetzt eigentlich welches Programm...
...ihr kennt das ja vielleicht...
...es gibt unter Linux mehrere Möglichkeiten Software zu installieren...
...ganz einfach...
...Pacman...
...entweder zum Beispiel als Systempaket...
...bei Debian basierten Systemen wie Mint...
...zum Beispiel mit ABT bzw. ABT-GET...
...bei Arch basierten Distributionen mit Pacman...
...oder halt zum Beispiel als...
...oder mit einem...
...der tausend...
...User-Repo-Helper...
...weil wenn ich zum Beispiel...
...ein VM-Champ installieren will...
...kann ich das auch über Yay...
...machen oder über...
...was verwenden die coolen Leute jetzt...
...Yay ist ja written in Go...
...und nicht mehr angesagt...
...Paru oder so heißt es...
...oder so in der Richtung...
...das verwenden die coolen Leute jetzt...
...weil written in Rust und placingly fast...
...und rewrite everything in Rust...
...und Krustentiere...
...United und was es alles gibt...
...warum Go-Bashing...
...ja nicht ich...
...nicht ich...
...muss sich beim Internet umgucken...
...die coolen Leute rewriten heute alles in Rust...
...ich benutze ja selbst weiterhin...
...ein Go-Programm dafür...
...wie heißt denn der Krampel...
...ist das nicht Paru...
...doch Paru genau...
...das verwenden die coolen Leute jetzt...
...nicht mehr Yay...
...die verwenden Paru, weil...
...ist written in Rust...
...abletztens eine Diskussion geführt wegen Traffic...
...weil das in Go ist...
...also ich würde Traffic tatsächlich...
...ungern einsetzen...
...aber das liegt nicht daran, weil es written in Go ist...
...gibt es ein gutes Argument...
...ok...
...ich sehe ich muss dazu jetzt was sagen...
...gibt es ein gutes Argument...
...gegen Go? Nö...
...es gibt für Go...
...Moment...
...reden wir jetzt davon Software in Go zu entwickeln...
...da gibt es sicherlich viel Pro und Contra...
...oder geht es darum...
...Software zu benutzen, die in Go programmiert ist...
...weil wenn es darum geht, so wie es scheint...
...ist das vollkommen egal...
...in was die Software programmiert ist...
...solange es die für dein Betriebssystem...
...gibt und supportet wird...
...und das macht was du willst...
...dann ist vollkommen egal...
...ob die in Go, in C...
...in C Sharp, in meinetwegen sogar in Java...
...oder sonst was entwickelt wurde...
...ja das ist ein bescheuertes Argument...
...es ist sogar relativ gut...
...wenn was in Go programmiert wurde...
...zumindest zum Verteilen der Software...
...unter Linux...
...weil Go Programme laufen in der Regel...
...ohne externe Abhängigkeiten...
...rückwirkend auf allen Linux Distributionen...
...das gleiche Binary...
...bis Kernel...
...2638...
...wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe...
...also unter Linux...
...so Portability und sowas...
...ist Go das Beste was du haben kannst...
...und ansonsten...
...viele bekannte Produkte sind in Go...
...also ganz ehrlich ein Argument...
...wir benutzen diese Software nicht...
...weil sie in Go programmiert ist...
...ist total hängen geblieben...
...die Hälfte des...
...etwas moderneren Internets...
...bei Cloud Anbietern läuft...
...auf Go Basis...
...Kubernetes ist zum größten Teil in Go...
...Terraform ist in Go...
...und wenn ich jetzt noch ein bisschen überlegen würde...
...würden mir sehr viele Software einfallen...
...die in Go programmiert ist...
...welchen Reverse Proxy würdest du nutzen...
...wenn nicht Traffic...
...ist die Frage für was...
...HTTP Traffic...
...oder...
...TCP Traffic...
...also ganz ehrlich...
...ich würde standardmäßig immer...
...wenn wir jetzt mal vom Kubernetes Umfeld angehen...
...Nginx benutzen...
...den offiziellen...
...Github Ingress Nginx...
...so...
...den hier...
...den würde ich eigentlich pauschal erstmal allen anderen vorziehen...
...es sei denn es spricht irgendwas...
...Casa OS ausprobiert...
...nein das habe ich eben auf...
...auf Github gesehen...
...und bin nicht so ganz schlau draus geworden was es ist...
...eine Sache die es da gibt...
...ist...
...also guckt mal...
...Ingress Nginx...
...nicht Github...
...nicht Gitlab...
...Github...
...genau es gibt Ingress Nginx...
...und es gibt Nginx Ingress...
...das verwirrt immer ein bisschen...
...Ingress Nginx...
...ist der offizielle Ingress Controller...
...vom Kubernetes Projekt...
...der auf Nginx Basis ist...
...Nginx Ingress...
...ist der offizielle Nginx Ingress...
...vom Nginx Projekt...
...also ich würde eigentlich pauschal...
...immer den hier nehmen...
...und ansonsten nehme ich auch ganz gerne Nginx...
...ansonsten man kann...
...natürlich auch für was kleines...
...Caddy benutzen...
...Caddy finde ich auch sehr nice...
...wenn es sich nur um HTTP handelt...
...und wenn man automatisiert Let's Encrypt Zertifikate...
...ausstellen will mit HTTP Challenge...
...so einfach...
...Domain eintragen starten gut ist...
...also Caddy ist top...
...wenn man nicht mehr als 5 Konfigurationszeilen braucht...
...für alles andere Nginx...
...alternativ...
...wenn man...
...zum Beispiel noch mehr Anforderungen hat...
...dass man sagt hey...
...man will HTTP machen, TCP machen...
...UDP machen und was auch immer bei UDP...
...weiß ich gar nicht...
...man möchte HTTP machen, TCP und alles mögliche...
...Loudbalancen...
...dann kannst du Nginx verwenden...
...wobei ich sagen muss...
...ja geht, ist nicht verkehrt...
...man kann sich dann allerdings auch mal...
...die Möglichkeiten, was das angeht...
...oder...
...man könnte natürlich auch Traffic verwenden...
...allerdings ich persönlich mag Traffic nicht...
...weil ich die Traffic-Config...
...trash finde...
...Traffic-Config ist für mich...
...unverständlich kryptisch...
...Traffic ist gut...
...wenn man es...
...einsetzen kann in irgendwelchen Bereichen...
...wo es Provider für gibt...
...die...
...wo Traffic sich die Informationen herbeschaffen kann...
...was wohin gebalanced werden soll...
...dann ist das ok...
...also solange Traffic irgendwie...
...über Tags, Labels...
...Key-Value-Stores...
...wie auch immer...
...automatisch konfiguriert werden kann...
...ist Traffic ok...
...aber sobald man Traffic-Konfiguration...
...von Hand erstellen muss...
...ist Traffic abfuck...
...und dann stellt sich mir die Frage...
...warum sollte ich überhaupt Traffic verwenden...
...weil fürs automatisch konfigurieren...
...da kann ich auch einfach den offiziellen Nginx Ingress verwenden...
...also ich persönlich sehe...
...nicht wo...
...Traffic...
...sich anbietet...
...vielleicht...
...wenn man Docker Compose...
...verwendet...
...und dort...
...über Labels...
...mit Traffic...
...seine...
...Container...
...ansprechbar machen möchte...
...ja also...
...da könnte ich es mir noch...
...am ehesten vorstellen...
...da hat es auch ganz guten Support für...
...hat Traffic-Gateway-API...
...Unterstützung...
...wahrscheinlich schon...
...es ist ja im Kubernetes-Umfeld...
...semi-beliebt...
...also wenn ich was nehmen müsste...
...als Reverse-Proxy...
...es gibt zwei Sachen...
...die ich hauptsächlich benutze...
...Public ist...
...HTTP-only...
...zum Beispiel...
...hat eine Domain...
...hat eine kleine Web-Anwendung...
...also eine Backend-Anwendung...
...und die will man proxyen...
...hat die davor...
...drei Zeilen...
...man hat ein gültiges Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat...
...es funktioniert alles...
...sobald es ein bisschen komplizierter wird...
...und über diese drei Zeilen rausgeht...
...ja das haben wir tatsächlich...
...Docker-Compose-Traffic-Let's-Encrypt...
...bei Kadi wird es dann ein bisschen komplizierter...
...wenn man advancere Sachen machen will...
...zum Beispiel...
...TCP-Loadbalancen geht glaube ich mit Kadi...
...ohne Plugins gar nicht...
...ja dann brauchst du irgendwelche...
...Third-Party-Anwendungen...
...ist ein bisschen doof...
...Traffic könnte tatsächlich ganz gut...
...in Kombination sein, wenn man...
...Let's-Encrypt-DNS-Challenge...
...machen will...
...und selbst viel...
...konfigurieren möchte...
...weil in NGINX selbst muss man das über...
...Third-Party oder irgendwas Externes machen...
...also ich benutze eigentlich...
...solange es simpel und easy sein soll...
...und einfach funktionieren soll...
...ohne großartige...
...komplizierten Anforderungen mache ich Kadi...
...und ansonsten NGINX...
...fertig...
...wenn es vielleicht ganz spezielle Anforderungen braucht...
...dann noch HA-Proxy...
...fand den Artikel ganz gut...
...also...
...um was geht es da?
...
...bestimmt Rust...
...ja, Rust, selbstverständlich...
...mein Hauptargument...
...gegen Traffic ist, dass die Config...
...suckt...
...und dass eigentlich...
...es gar nicht notwendig ist...
...weil du den offiziellen...
...NGINX-Ingress verwenden kannst...
...und auch sonst immer NGINX...
...verwenden kannst, außer in ganz simplen Fällen...
...wenn du nichts konfigurieren willst...
...also...
...ich sehe halt den eher umgedreht...
...ich habe keine so großartigen...
...Argumente gegen Traffic...
...sondern ich habe eigentlich so gut wie keine...
...Argumente für Traffic...
...das ist es eigentlich...
...außer...
...also mein größtes Gegenargument für Traffic...
...wenn man Konfigurationen von Hand erstellen möchte...
...ist, dass die Konfiguration eklig...
...also für meinen Geschmack echt eklig ist...
...kann ich mal zeigen...
...auch schon diese Aufteilung...
...zwischen dynamischer Konfig...
...und Running-Konfig...
...seriously...
...das sieht so abartig aus...
...außerdem ist überhaupt nicht klar...
...wie du Sachen schreiben musst...
...das ist so eklig...
...guckt euch das an...
...wie die Konfig aussieht...
...NGINX-Konfig...
...ist ja auch schon nicht...
...ein glänzendes Beispiel...
...einer tollen Konfigurationsdatei...
...war immer noch besser als Apache-Konfig...
...erinnert sich noch jemand dran...
...wer von euch hatte schon mal die Ehre...
...Apache-Konfigs...
...Rewrite-Rules in Apache von Hand schreiben zu müssen...
...was ist JetBrains Gateway?
...was ist das?
...das ist...
...da kann man quasi...
...per SSH auf seine...
...Linux-VM...
...und seine Windows-PC...
...als Frontend dafür benutzen...
...eigentlich ganz cool...
...ich weiß gar nicht was...
...PodMap...
...und NerdCTL...
...überhaupt ist...
...hab ich noch nie gehört...
...Docker...
...ach Docker-kompatibel...
...Container-D...
...und was ist PodMap?
...ah du meinst Podman...
...TCP-Loadbalancer...
...wie kann man sich das vorstellen?
...ja genau so...
...äh...
...ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll...
...also was kann man sich da nicht dran vorstellen?
...da machst du es halt auf Verbindungsebene...
...und nicht auf Request-Ebene...
...schickst halt den ersten Request ein...
...äh...
...machst halt mehrere Verbindungen auf...
...zu deinen Backends...
...und da kommt ein Paket...
...das geht dann dahin...
...auf Port 443...
...und das nächste geht dahin auf Port 443...
...Port 443 machst du nicht so wirklich...
...du kannst ja auch TCP-Packages...
...beziehungsweise eigentlich musst du...
...TCP-Sessions besser Loadbalancen...
...Packages alleine ist natürlich blödsinnig...
...ja...
...also im Prinzip kannst du dir das so vorstellen...
...du hast einen Loadbalancer und dahinter...
...keine Ahnung...
...4 VMs mit Services drauf...
...und da kommt ein...
...TCP-Syn-Package an...
...und das wird...
...auf einen der Backends-Systeme weitergeleitet...
...so und dann wird die Verbindung darüber aufgebaut...
...da kommt das nächste Syn-Package an...
...aufs nächste, aufs nächste, aufs nächste, dann wieder aufs erste...
...du baust halt TCP-Verbindungen auf...
...auf unterschiedliche Backends...
...du musst dir halt nur von deinem Loadbalancer merken...
...wohin was muss...
...das ist aber ganz...
...normale Praxis...
...und unterstützt auch fast alles...
...alle Loadbalancing-Produkte...
...und brauchst du ja oftmals...
...du willst ja nicht immer nur...
...HTTP-Loadbalancen...
...vielleicht ja auch mal was anderes...
...es ist zwar hauptsächlich...
...HTTP, aber nicht immer...
...ja dafür ist das gut...
...wie gesagt, wenn man Docker-Compose-Gedöns benutzt...
...ist es gut...
...es gibt niemanden, der das wirklich versteht, oder?
...wir haben tatsächlich schon mal ein bisschen Rust gemacht...
...aber ich raste immer aus, wenn ich Rust machen muss...
...so...
...ich würde sagen, wir sollten mal mit dem Video weitermachen...
...wir haben es jetzt geschafft, ganze 3 Minuten uns anzugucken...
...und ich hab ewig geschwätzt dazu schon...
...es sind einzelne Verbindungen...
...und nicht der Verbindungsaufbau gemeint...
...naja, es ist beides gemeint...
...bei TCP gibt es ja immer...
...diese Handshake-Geschichte...
...und bei einem TCP-Loadbalancer...
...bringt es dir ja nichts...
...wenn du paketweise die Sachen...
...weiter schickst...
...du musst das erste Paket halt...
...zu einem Endpunkt schicken...
...dann macht der mit der Quelle...
...dann geht es wieder zurück...
...dann wird Handshake mit dem eigentlichen...
...Anfrage...
...und dann musst du halt nur gucken...
...dass die...
...Packages, die zu einer Session gehören...
...immer...
...auf den gleichen...
...auf das gleiche Backend...
...gehen...
...da gibt es doch bestimmt...
...irgendwelche schönen...
...Bilder dafür...
...ja, ok...
...dümmer und abstrakter könnten wir es nicht mehr machen...
...ist auch falsch...
...das sieht schon besser aus...
...ja, genau das...
...das ist gut, das ist das was ich eben...
...versucht habe zu beschreiben, genau...
...der Client schickt einen SYN-Pack...
...einen TCP-SYN...
...an die IP vom Loadbalancer...
...der Loadbalancer guckt...
...nach welchen Kriterien auch immer...
...ja, welcher...gibt ja mehrere Möglichkeiten...
...nach denen du Loadbalancen kannst...
...du kannst sagen einfach abwechselnd oder...
...wer hat die geringsten Verbindungen, wie auch immer...
...wählt der Loadbalancer ein Ziel aus...
...dann wird das SYN-Package zurückgeschickt...
...dann antwortet der Server mit einem SYN-Arg...
...das SYN-Arg geht an den Client zurück...
...und in Wirklichkeit hat der Client eine Verbindung...
...mit diesem Backend-Server aufgebaut...
...weiß es aber nicht, weil es für ihn aussieht als Endpunkt...
...dass es dieser Loadbalancer ist...
...das einzige was dieser Loadbalancer jetzt machen muss ist...
...wenn das nächste Package...
...dieser Verbindung kommt...
...muss der sicherstellen...
...dass das da hingeht...
...dazu wird er sich wahrscheinlich...
...irgendwelche Mapping-Tabellen speichern...
...oder Approxination und keine Ahnung...
...genau...
...genau so funktioniert es...
...das ist tatsächlich das schwierige an einem TCP-Loadbalancer...
...der muss sich halt merken...
...wohin er welche Verbindungsanfragen geschickt hat...
...und danach geht das weiter...
...ist eigentlich ziemlich Standard...
...kann so gut wie jedes Loadbalancing-Produkt...
...nginx kann es auch...
...nginx kann das auch...
...kadi kann es glaube ich nicht out of the box...
...wo wir da beim Fall sind...
...simple Sachen mit kadi, alles was komplizierter wird...
...nginx...
...aproxy kann es auch...
...aproxy kann es sogar relativ simpel...
...so jetzt gucken wir aber wirklich das Video mal fertig...
...eine Software...
...zu installieren...
...entweder z.B. als Systempaket...
...bei Debian-basierten Systemen wie Mint...
...z.B. mit apt bzw. apt-get...
...bei Arch-basierten Distributionen...
...oder halt z.B. als distributionsübergreifendes...
...Paket wie z.B. Flatpak...
...der Vorteil von Flatpak ist...
...dass das wie gesagt...
...übergreifend läuft...
...d.h. die Software muss nicht wie bei Systempaketen...
...minutiös an die Distri angepasst werden...
...weil alle benötigten Bibliotheken...
...mit im Paket liegen...
...deshalb sind sie meist auch aktueller...
...als Nachteil von Flatpak...
...aber Flatpak hat glaube ich ein paar...
...Anforderungen...
...ich glaube Flatpak braucht glaube ich...
...Debus was läuft und sowas...
...das ordentlich funktioniert...
...leider ist Flatpak so kein universelles...
...standalone...
...Package-Format, das ist ein bisschen doof...
...es wäre cool...
...wenn Flatpak so eine Art besseres App-Image wäre...
...es gilt oft...
...dass die Sachen erstmal mehr Speicherplatz brauchen...
...eben weil ja die ganzen Bibliotheken da mit drin sind...
...aber Pakete teilen sich gleiche Datenblöcke...
...d.h. häufig verwendete Bibliotheken...
...nehmen bei zusätzlichen Installationen...
...keinen zusätzlichen Platz ein...
...das Speicherargument fällt also nicht wirklich ins Gewicht...
...in der MINT-Anwendungsverwaltung...
...kann man bei vielen Programmen aussuchen...
...ob man die als Systempaket...
...gibt es schon Flatpak als Gegenstück?
...das wäre nice...
...Fatpak...
...JetBrains supporten nur Snap?
...weiß nicht...
...ich habe Snap bei mir nicht installiert...
...ich installiere alles über das JetBrains Toolkit...
...und das installiert es ganz normal...
...bei mir im Heimatverzeichnis...
...wurde Snap schon gebashed?
...ne, aber ich mag Snap nicht...
...als älteren Version oder als Flatpak...
...in einer neueren Version installieren...
...einfach so per Dropdown-Menü...
...und Linux MINT denkt auch im Detail...
Sekunde, Chat, ich muss tatsächlich noch was beantworten...
...hast du schon mal mit dem...
...Netzwerklastenausgleichs-Manager...
...von Windows Server gearbeitet?
...der Name allein schon...
...ist wieder so geil...
...dass du das jetzt nicht ausgedacht haben kannst...
...das heißt wahrscheinlich wirklich so, oder?
...ey...
...ganz ehrlich...
...ich verstehe warum man Windows auf dem Desktop verwendet...
...das kann ich nachvollziehen...
...aber warum...
...jemand so krank gestört sein kann...
...Windows auf dem Server zu verwenden...
...leuchtet mir...
...wird mir nie einleuchten...
...und damit mehr als Active Directory...
...weil es sein muss zu machen...
...keine Ahnung, wie man so verrückt sein kann...
...man kann nämlich Systempaket und Flatpak-Version...
...gleichzeitig installieren...
...wenn man das macht...
...ach, das ist nice, das wusste ich nicht...
...ich glaube wir müssen uns mal wieder ein neues Linux MINT angucken...
...demnächst, schon ein bisschen her...
...man kann nämlich Systempaket und Flatpak-Version...
...gleichzeitig installieren...
...das finde ich gut, das finde ich nice...
...ich meine, die...
...über Updiversion dürften wahrscheinlich...
...eine ganze Ecke älter sein als über Flatpak...
...aber vielleicht wenn man was neues ausprobieren...
...dass man das parallel...
...dass man das parallel installiert...
...das finde ich ist eine gute Sache...
...gibt es andere Alternativen zu einem Active Directory...
...nee, deswegen sage ich ja auch...
...ähm...
...wenn man Active Directory machen will...
...aber ansonsten verstehe ich nicht...
...wie man Windows Server verwenden kann...
...installieren...
...und wenn man das macht, wird im Startmenü...
...hinter der Flatpak-Version auch Flatpak angezeigt...
...damit man weiß, welches welche Version ist...
...richtig? Finde ich gut...
...ja, ich weiß, andere Linux-Distries haben...
...auch so ähnliche Programminstallationstools...
...aber ich fand bislang keines so schön...
...wie das von Linux MINT...
...Grund Nummer 2...
...Linux MINT ist ein Anti-Ubuntu...
...obwohl es auf Ubuntu basiert...
...ja, das ist ein kurioser Widerspruch...
...Linux MINT wird von einem vergleichsweise...
...kleinen Entwicklungsteam betreut...
...und das ist nur möglich, weil große Teile...
...vom großen Ubuntu verwendet werden...
...Linux MINT ist also quasi ein Ubuntu-Remix...
...das aber konsequent Dinge anders machen will...
...als Ubuntu...
...während Ubuntu z.B. standardmäßig als Desktop-Umgebung...
...ein aktuelles GNOME verwendet...
...nimmt MINT das selbstentwickelte Cinnamon...
...das vereinfacht gesagt...
...auf einer älteren GNOME-Version basiert...
...so hat GNOME seit Version 3...
...keine klassische Taskleiste mehr...
...generell kann man sagen, dass Linux MINT...
...GNOME hat auch seit einem der letzten Versionen...
...kein Minimieren-Button mehr...
...wo ich mir jetzt immer denke...
...was ist mit den Leuten los, Alter...
...wenn ich einen Tiling-Window-Manager benutze...
...ja, dann brauche ich keinen Minimieren-Button...
...wenn ich einen...
...ganz normalen GNOME-Desktop...
...mit Fenstern und Rumgeschiebe verwende...
...dann brauche ich einen Minimieren-Button...
...aber in GNOME gibt es keinen Minimieren-Button mehr...
...in GNOME 2 hattest du Minimieren-Button...
...selbstverständlich...
...weil die Bedienung etwas konservativer ist...
...und sich eher so ein bisschen...
...Windows 10-mäßig anfühlt...
...während GNOME inzwischen sein eigenes Ding macht...
...Windows-Leute dürften sich mit Linux MINT...
...direkt Zuhause fühlen...
...so ganz gemütlich...
...links unten der Start-Button...
...daneben die Programme-Icons...
...rechts die Schnelleinstellungen...
...ganz rechts die Uhrzeit...
...anders als Windows ist Linux MINT...
...aber viel stärker anpassbar...
...unter Themen kann man zum Beispiel...
...und da sind wirklich ziemlich hübsche Sachen dabei...
...ich benutze zum Beispiel als Mauszeiger...
...Bibatta Modern Classic...
...als Desktop- und Fenster-Design...
...Leute kennt ihr noch jemand...
...der den Mauszeiger benutzt?
...ich kenn da auch jemand...
...der diesen Mauszeiger verwendet...
...allerdings in der orangen Version...
...ich hab den gleichen Mauszeiger...
...nur ich hab ihn in orange...
...Adapter Noctua...
...und als Icon Set Breeze...
...das ist auch das Design...
...was ihr am Rest dieses Videos sehen werdet...
...das Hintergrundbild habe ich auch...
...aus den von MINT vorinstallierten Bildern genommen...
...Grund Nummer 3...
...Linux MINT macht alles mit Clicky-Bunty...
...statt mit Tippen...
...Dinge für die man sonst Terminal-Befehle braucht...
...oder Config-Dateien editieren muss...
...macht MINT auf Wunsch...
...sehr simpel per Mausklick...
...was mich regelrecht erschüttert hat...
...ich hab mal eben in wenigen Sekunden...
...mit zwei Klicks den Kernel ausgetauscht...
...Linux MINT ist, sagte ich ja schon...
...eher konservativ...
...und nutzt den schon etwas älteren...
...Langzeit-Unterstützungskernel 5.15...
...wenn man...
...das hält aber unter Windows MINT...
...das hält unter Linux MINT...
...auch nur so lange...
...bis man wirklich mal...
...irgendwas hat, was nicht funktioniert...
...und man genauer nachgucken muss...
...und...
...ich hab's ja in meinem Video gesagt...
...ich will mich gar nicht so lange drüber auslassen...
...es ist eigentlich ein Vorteil von Linux...
...dass du ein ordentliches Terminal hast...
...so diese Geschichte mit...
...Terminal ist so...
...rückständig, ich will nicht ins Terminal...
...sobald ich ins Terminal muss...
...ist das 1990, ist ja verkehrt...
...das denken die Leute...
...wegen CMD unter Windows...
...weil das so Oldschool-Bullshit ist...
...aber unter Linux ist das ja eigentlich ganz gut...
...es ist echt schön...
...dass die 0.8.15 Sachen übers UI gehen...
...aber sobald man mal irgendwas...
...nachgucken muss, zum Beispiel...
...nehmen wir mal an...
...irgendjemand will mit Wine...
...was starten, was sonst unter Linux nicht läuft...
...und muss dann in irgendwelchen...
...Wine-Configs irgendwelche Tweaks...
...machen oder was auch immer...
...du kommst früher oder später...
...nicht drumherum...
...mal ein bisschen was auf Command-Line zu machen...
...oder du steckst ein USB-Gerät an...
...und aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
...geht's nicht richtig...
...vielleicht ist es ein Bug...
...oder du bekommst im Internet den Hinweis...
...ja, passt doch mal diese UDEV-Regel an...
...dann geht es...
...ja, mach viel Spaß das mit nem UI zu machen...
...Windows hat doch auch Bash...
...ne, Windows hat PowerShell...
...aber PowerShell ist Müll als interaktives Shell...
...mittlerweile haben sie wenigstens SSH dabei...
...wenn man hier in die Aktualisierungsverwaltung geht...
...und dann unter Ansicht auf Linux-Körnel...
...kann man einfach so den aktuellen...
...6.2er-Körnel installieren...
...und wenn damit was nicht funktioniert...
...kann man einfach so wieder zurück wechseln...
...kurzer Hintergrund, falls ihr euch fragt...
...wozu es überhaupt gut sein soll...
...im Körnel stecken unter anderem die Systemtreiber...
...das heißt, wenn ihr aktuelle Hardware habt...
...kann es sein, dass Sachen erst mit einem neueren Körnel laufen...
...oder halt stabiler...
...kann man ja einfach ausprobieren...
...muss man aber natürlich nicht, wenn alles zufriedenstellend läuft...
...Grund Nummer 4...
...alles funktioniert auch...
...Warum ist PowerShell Müll? PowerShell ist nicht Müll...
...PowerShell ist ziemlich gut, wenn du irgendwas scripten...
...und automatisieren willst...
...aber nicht das tägliche Terminal...
...Arbeitsumgebung nicht...
...wenn du Skripte-Automatisierung bauen willst...
...ist PowerShell ziemlich nice...
...aber so als Interaktive...
...ich arbeite und administriere das System...
...schell mag ich PowerShell überhaupt nicht...
Out of the Box...
...ja ich weiß, Linux ist aus dem Problembär-Status raus...
...auch andere Linux laufen super einfach...
...wir hatten ja schon mal ein Video über Endeavor gemacht...
...aber ich muss sagen...
...Arch by the way...
...hier mit Mint war das alles noch einen Tacken smoother...
...schaut mal hier, das ist die Installation...
...einfach ISO runterladen...
...mit Etcher auf USB-Stick kopieren...
...beim Systemstart...
...ich bin ja immer noch ein bisschen getriggert...
...auch wenn ich das selbst benutze Leute...
...wo sind wir eigentlich angekommen?
...kann mir irgendjemand das schlüssig erklären...
...wie wir es geschafft haben...
...dass man ein Image auf ein USB-Stick flashen...
...heute einen Browser verbraucht...
...warum brauche ich...
...einen Node.js und einen Browser...
...um ein Image auf ein USB-Stick zu bekommen?
...ich verstehe es nicht...
...und ja, ich benutze den Kram selbst...
...einfach hauptsächlich weil ich zu faul bin...
...DD einzutippen und dann...
...DD, IF gleich...
...Blob, OF, BS gleich...
...aber...
...warum?
...ich rede jetzt unter Linux...
...warum brauche ich einen Browser?
...ich verwende auch Disk-Imager...
...das ging so weit, dass ich...
...genau, dass...
...geali...
...genau, dass gealiast habe...
...Edger auf USB-Imager...
...ähm...
...ich hatte ein Problem mit USB-Imager...
...deswegen habe ich ihn wieder runter geschmissen...
...und deswegen installiere ich jetzt auch wieder Edger...
...ähm...
...heißt das jetzt anders?
...Leute, ich habe Edger installiert...
...aber ich kann...
...und wie heißt es...
...Executable davon?
...keine Ahnung...
...ist das wirklich ein Browser?
...ja...
...weiß nicht, gibt es davon den Source-Code?
...eventuell ist was, wenn du mehrere...
...Sachen drauf machen willst...
...nicht, wenn du einfach nur mal schnell ein Image flashen willst...
...ja, das ist ein Browser...
...das ist irgendeine Elektron-Anwendung...
...weiß nicht, wo sieht man das am besten...
...was ist passiert?
...Package-Json, wahrscheinlich...
...guck, das ist ein Browser...
...Elektron...
...das ist ein Browser, Edger...
...auf USB-Stick kopieren...
...beim Systemstart, wenn ihr Windows benutzt...
...auf Standard-Einstellungen ändern...
...oder andere Optionen auswählen...
...dann weitere Optionen auswählen...
...dann ein Gerät verwenden und dann den USB-Datenträger auswählen...
...dann bootet der Rechner vom USB-Stick...
...echt?
...ich hätte jetzt einfach...
...F12 oder so für das Boot-Menü gedrückt...
...hier im Menü einmal Return drücken...
...und dann, wenn der Desktop geladen ist...
...auf Install Linux Mint doppelklicken...
...Sprache auswählen, weiter...
...Multimedia-Kodex anwählen...
...und wenn ihr das parallel zu Windows installieren wollt...
...Linux Mint neben den Windows Boot-Manager installieren...
...und los!
...ich hatte auf meinem System einfach einen 200 GB...
...macht Windows eigentlich bei seinen...
...jährlichen Updates immer noch...
...andere Boot-Manager regelmäßig kaputt?
...das war ja ein Problem...
...ja...
...dreckiges Ding, Alter...
...dreckiges Software...
...das war ja regelmäßig ein Problem...
...weil diese...
...diese jährlichen Updates ja oftmals...
...eine Neuinstallation sind...
...und wenn das halt mal wieder der Fall ist, dann...
...Reich frei, also wo keine Partition hinterlegt war...
...und der Mint-Installer hat das automatisch erkannt...
...und einfach dahin installiert...
...im UEFI bei Boot-Reihenfolge...
...auf Ubuntu umstellen...
...dann habt ihr's...
...ach so, solltet ihr irgendwelche Probleme haben...
...müsst ihr womöglich im UEFI Secure Boot ausschalten...
...ja, jedenfalls lief dann bei mir in unter 10 Minuten...
...das installierte Linux Mint System...
...ziemlich nice...
...auch das erste Schritte-Fenster...
...das nach dem Starten angezeigt wird...
...ist super zielführend und auf den Punkt...
...und das hab ich woanders schon ganz anders gesehen...
...hier, einfach System-Snapshots anlegen...
...Treiber-Verwaltung...
...wo ich zum Beispiel ganz einfach den neuesten Nvidia-Grafiktreiber...
...installieren kann...
...Aktualisierungs-Verwaltung, System-Einstellung...
...alles was man braucht...
...und auch alles komplett lokalisiert, also auf Deutsch...
...in anderen Disziplinen...
...das erste was ich im Installer gemacht hätte...
...dass ich's auf Englisch installieren will...
...aber es spricht ja schon mal dafür...
...und nicht so wie Microsoft...
...dass der Projekt-Mappen-Manager...
...Erstellungs-Assistent...
...der Projekt-Mappen-Manager-Verwaltung...
...aufgehört hat zu funktionieren...
...habe ich schon oft so...
...Sprachmischmasch gesehen...
...Thema Spiele...
...ich kann in der Anwendungsverwaltung...
...einfach Steam installieren...
...ja und dann hier in Steam unter...
...Kompatibilität, Steamplay aktivieren...
...zack, fertig...
...und dann geht fast alles was ich in der Steam-Bibliothek habe...
...das klappt natürlich in den meisten Linuxen so...
...aber ich hatte zum Beispiel bei Endeavor...
...mit Steam anfangs einige Themen...
...zum Beispiel mit Elden Ring...
...weil das den Nuvo-Kopierschutz hat...
...und der manchmal Probleme macht...
...aber hier in Mint, alles was ich in Steam gestartet habe, ging...
...und während ich bei anderen Linux-Distries...
...oft rumsuchen musste...
...wo ich bestimmte Programme finde...
...hatte ich bei Mint so gut wie immer direkt...
...in der Anwendungsverwaltung Erfolg...
...auch so Sachen wie das berüchtigte Microsoft Teams...
...gingen auf Anhieb...
...in der Web-Version und zwar inklusive...
...meines externen USB-Mikrofons und der Webcam...
...lediglich so ein kleiner Schönheitsfehler...
...ist mir aufgefallen...
...wenn sich mein Monitor in den Stromsparmodus abschaltet...
...und bei Mint der Login-Screen läuft...
...kann ich den Monitor nicht mit Mausbewegungen...
...oder Leertaste oder so aufwecken...
...ich muss dann blind mein Passwort eingeben...
...und erst dann schaltet sich der Monitor wieder ein...
...naja, kann man mit leben...
...Grund Nummer 5, man muss sich nicht umgewöhnen...
...das kann man jetzt natürlich schlecht finden...
...weil man nach dem wahren, echten...
...ein einzigartigen Linux-Gefühl sucht...
...aber Linux Mint funktioniert halt einfach so...
...dass die meisten Menschen, die Windows kennen...
...auf Anhieb damit klarkommen...
...Startmenü, Task-Preise, Kontextmenü...
...über Rechtsklick und sogar diese schöne...
...Snap-In-Feature von Windows...
...dass die Fenster entweder zweigeteilt...
...oder viergeteilt hier so einrastet...
...alles da, ich würde sogar die rasante These aufstellen...
...dass Leute, die sich nicht für Computer interessieren...
...und hin und wieder mal Windows benutzen müssen...
...das gar nicht merken würden...
...wenn man denen so ein Linux Mint vorsieht...
...ja und für die Oma...
...wäre das sogar besser...
...weil die Oma sich dann...
...keine Malware irgendwie einfangen kann...
...am besten noch das von Windows bekannte...
...Hintergrundbild einstellen...
...oder liege ich da total falsch...
...hat das von euch vielleicht sogar jemand schon mal ausprobiert...
...gerne in die Kommentare schreiben...
...find ich sehr interessant...
...Grund Nummer 6...
...alles dabei, was man braucht...
...und nix dabei, was nervt...
...klar, das gilt für viele Linuxer...
...Kram, den man gar nicht haben will...
...bei Linux Mint dagegen gibt es das nicht...
...dafür alles, was man haben will...
...also zumindest hätte ich die Vorauswahl...
...vermutlich überhaupt nicht anders gemacht...
...es ist die letzten Jahre...
...schon wirklich ganz gut geworden...
...also ich habe das ja verfolgt...
...seit, frag mich nicht, wann habe ich damit angefangen...
...keine Ahnung, 2005 oder so...
...sich mit Linux zu beschäftigen...
...und...
...vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen früher...
...ich weiß nicht...
...und...
...es war schon ein langer Weg...
...aber ein Ding...
...müssen wir Valve wirklich...
...gaben...
...müssen wir uns bei...
...habe ich ihn hier nicht irgendwo...
...müssen wir uns bei Gaben bedanken...
...dass so viele...
...Gaming-Sachen mittlerweile unter Linux...
...problemlos funktionieren, das hätte es ohne...
...Steam und Valve nicht gegeben...
...würdet ihr sagen, Linux braucht im privaten Bereich...
...keinen Virenscanner? Ja, würde ich sagen...
...du brauchst keinen Virenscanner...
...ich wüsste noch nicht mal...
...was es da...
...an so Windows-Style...
...Virenscanner gibt, es gab irgendwie...
...Klammer-V früher und sowas...
...das war ja aber eher zum Durchsuchen...
...von irgendwelchen Samba-Shares...
...ich wüsste gar nicht, ob es ordentlich...
...doch, du kannst Windows Defender für Linux installieren...
...nee, du brauchst keinen...
...das würde ich sagen, dass du...
...brauchst keinen...
...Antivirus...
...ein Virenscanner gehört für Mails...
...LibreOffice fürs Büro...
...und obendrein noch ein paar nette Goodies...
...gerne herumgespielt habe ich z.B. mit dem...
...vollinstallierten Hypnotix...
...was einfach eine schöne Benutzeroberfläche...
...mit freiempfangbaren TV-Kanal und Film-Streams ist...
...da kann ich chinesisches Fernsehen gucken...
...oder MTV oder irgendwelche 80er Trash-Filme...
...wirklich nett...
...mein Fazit...
...Linux Mint ist eine Linux-Distribution...
...bei der der Einstieg extrem leicht fällt...
...und zwar auch für Leute, die bislang nur Windows kannten...
...wer so ein hochmodernes...
...Cutting-Edge-Linux will, ist hier vermutlich...
...aber nicht an der richtigen Adresse...
...obwohl man damit natürlich genauso frickeln kann...
...wie mit anderen Linuxen, wenn man dazu Lust hat...
...aber die Desktop-Umgebung...
...also das Kern-Feature von Mint...
...ist halt das etwas konservative...
...Windows-mäßige Cinnamon...
...ich muss sagen, dass ich das aktuelle Gnome...
...rein vom optischen her etwas cooler...
...und futuristischer finde...
...aber so wie ich mir mein Mint hier eingestellt habe...
...gefällt mir das auch schon wirklich gut...
...mir ist angenehm, dass ich nach Programmen...
...nicht nervig herumsuchen muss...
...sondern in den allermeisten Fällen...
...in der Anwendungsverwaltung...
...mein Fazit zu Mint...
...ich würde das auch allen Einsteigern ans Herz legen...
...funktioniert halt einfach...
...und deshalb werde ich Mint hier jetzt auch erstmal behalten...
...und wenn ich auch noch einen Wunsch frei hätte...
...hätte ich gerne exakt den gleichen...
...Comfort-Level, den Linux Mint bietet...
...aber mit einem moderneren Gnome...
...und mit Wayland als Compositor...
...also quasi die Schnittstelle, die den Desktop anzeigt...
...Mint benutzt hier nach das sehr...
...ja, wenn dann in Wayland mal ordentlich alles funktioniert...
...4TX11...
...vielleicht gucke ich mir mal Nubara Linux an...
...das ist ein auf Spiele optimiertes Fedora...
...über das ich schon viel Gutes gehört habe...
...würde euch dazu ein Video interessieren...
...gerne auch in die Kommentare schreiben...
...und natürlich abonnieren...
...Tschüss!
Basieren alle Linux-Distributionen...
...auf dem selben Kernel?
Prinzipiell ja...
...nicht unbedingt in der gleichen Version...
...aber deswegen ist...
...Linux...
...ist Mint nicht End of Life?
...äh?
Im Prinzip heißt Linux ja genau aus dem Grund...
...Linux, weil sie alle auf Linux basieren...
...also...
...ja, das ist überall der gleiche Kernel...
...wenn auch nicht unbedingt in der gleichen Version immer...
...aber prinzipiell schon...
...ja...
...das kommt ein bisschen drauf an...
...so pauschal erstmal nicht...
...das liegt aber nicht an Linux...
...das liegt an Libc...
...die...
...sich nicht so...
...gerne austauschen lässt...
...wenn was dagegen kompiliert wurde...
...wenn du Sachen...
...in Go verwendest, ist das gar kein Problem...
...Go-Programme...
...oder generell...
...Programme, die da keine Abhängigkeit drauf haben...
...laufen...
...also bei Go ist das ein bestes Beispiel...
...weil Go...
...jede...das gleiche...
...Go-Binary...
...und die gleiche Go-Exe...
...für Windows-Leute...
...laufen unter allen...
...Linux-Versionen seit...
...Kernel 2.6.38...
...und 2.6.38...
...Linux ist alt...
...der ist von...
...März 2011...
...ja...
...also es ist 12 Jahre alt...
...und auf allen da läuft rückwirkend...
...das gleiche Go-Binary...
...also gescheit...gescheit gemacht...
...geht das...
...was war die Frage...
...ja Scaling und 4K...
...habe ich auch schon öfters gehört, dass das ein bisschen Probleme macht...
...also ich hatte ja auch...
...ich hatte i3...
...auf meinem...
...227 Zoll Curved...
...4K Monitor...
...und da musste ich halt auch...
...alles ein bisschen größer stellen...
...aber im Großen und Ganzen ging es ganz gut...
...interject for a moment...
...ja und wenn du das in font-config...
...anpassen musst...
...wo wir wieder beim Thema Terminal und Kommando-Zeile sind...
...ja...
...früher oder später wirst du nicht drum herum kommen...
...so was haben wir denn sonst noch...
...was können wir uns noch angucken...
...ein, zwei Sachen können wir noch schauen...
...150 IQ...
...was ist das...
...oh das ist der...
...der Apple-Fan...
...was ist...Dyson Zone...
...Kopfhörer mit Luftfilter in der Praxis...
...okay...
...ich dachte eigentlich...
...das ist vorbei...
...aber es kann ja durchaus auch Sinn machen...
...außerhalb von Corona und Maskenkram...
...je nachdem wo man unterwegs ist...
...so Beispiel Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof in manchen Ecken...
...seine eigene Luft...
...oder seinen Luftfilter dabei zu haben...
...mich interessiert mal wie das aussieht...
...sieht wahrscheinlich ultra beknackt aus...
...viel wurde über den Dyson Zone gesagt...
...und gelacht...
...und dass das alles nicht funktionieren kann...
...und sowieso totaler Quatsch ist...
...okay es sieht da richtig bescheuert aus...
...ich meine Masken sahen teilweise schon bescheuert aus...
...aber das ging noch...
...und vor allem weil es zu dem Zeitpunkt alle auf hatten...
...das war nicht so wirklich wild...
...aber das Ding sieht wirklich bescheuert aus...
...viel wurde über den Dyson Zone gesagt...
...und gelacht...
...und dass das alles nicht funktionieren kann...
...und sowieso totaler Quatsch ist...
...aber ihr wisst...
...ich bin heute in der Öffentlichkeit um zu sehen...
...wie albern man sich vorkommt...
...ich habe zum Glück gerade eine Baustelle...
...wo ich Geräuschunterdrückung und Luftfilterung...
...in einem Abwasch ausprobieren konnte...
...und ich habe mich auch dem mondänen Leben...
...damit hingegeben...
...von all dem berichte ich heute...
...aber fangen wir vorne bei dem Anruf an...
...lasst uns mal kurz gucken was das kostet...
...Dyson Zone...
...Kopfhörer...
...alter...
...boah...
...das ist ordentlich...
...959 Euro...
...alter...
...was haben die da für Kopfhörer...
...das muss ja die...
...also ich meine der Luftfilter alleine reißt ja nicht raus...
...das muss ja...
...sonst was verbaut sein da drinnen...
...by the way...
...ich wusste gar nicht dass Dyson Kopfhörer macht...
...und sowas...
...ich bringe Dysoner hauptsächlich...
...mit Staubsaugern in Verbindung...
...ich wusste gar nicht dass die auch Kopfhörer haben...
...ach die haben...
...Best Audio Awards...
...ist das so...
...ja gut bei 59...
...ja so Leute...
...jeder in der Öffentlichkeit...
...und du hast natürlich auch eigenen Chauffeur und alles...
...und deswegen...
...so läuft man immer durch die Öffentlichkeit...
...wenn man Kopfhörer auf hat...
...da ist man immer so permanent am Dancen und am Grooven...
...und fühlt das so richtig...
...gut das ist ein Werbevideo...
...aber wie gesagt...
...Dyson sind für mich Hersteller von Staubsaugern...
...von so teilweise leicht...
...futuristisch aussehenden Staubsaugern...
...wenn die Apple Brille erscheint...
...wird sich erstmal gar nichts tun...
...es wird sich vielleicht was tun...
...in ein paar Jahren...
...wenn die Leute die jetzt anfangen...
...für die Apple Brille...
...was zu entwickeln...
...und coole Anwendungsszenarien rauskommen...
...und dann die Leute sich nach und nach kaufen...
...bevor wir spielverderberisch...
...mit Sinnfragen...
...meine Kontakte bei Dyson gegen mich aufbringen...
...um ein endgültiges Urteil...
...zumindest für mich zu fällen...
...habe ich sie jetzt hier...
...die Dyson Zone Absolut Plus...
...wurden mir freundlicherweise für Dyson...
...für dieses Video zur Verfügung gestellt...
...aber wie ihr wisst hatten wir das schon bei anderen Produkten...
...und das ist nicht so gut ausgegangen...
...also finden wir heute mal raus...
...was es mit den Dyson Zone Absolut Plus...
...Kopfhörern mit Geräuschunterdrückung...
...und dem optionalen Visier...
...Luftqualitätsverschlechterungsunterdrückung...
...auf sich hat...
...es ist ein...
...kontaktloses Airflow Visier...
...das zwei Ströme an Luft...
...in deine Nase und Mund...
...atmet...
...gleichzeitig bietet es...
...immersiven, hochauflösenden Klang...
...mit fortgeschrittener Geräuschunterdrückung...
...es hat Sensoren...
...es sind Dinge verbaut...
...ja Werbung halt...
...meine erste Hürde wird ja schon mal sein...
...ich bin so ein bisschen gespannt, ob mir das überhaupt passt...
...der Kopf ist riesig...
...möchte er damit sagen, er ist quasi ein...
...Fivehead...
...wird sein, wenn es mir passt...
...ich meine, High IQ Videos macht er ja schon...
...die Handwerker werden mich...
...für völlig irre halten, wenn ich mit diesem...
...mit diesem Apparat da...
...auf der Baustelle auflaufe...
...naja, wir schauen mal...
...das wird auf jeden Fall für Erhalterung sorgen...
...so erwartet...
...ja gut, der Spul...
...der Spul ich jetzt mal ein bisschen vor...
...die Kiste mit offenbar den Kopfhörern...
...Kiste mit...
...das sieht aus wie für irgendein Fernglas...
...oder sowas...
...USB-Kabel...
...ein Adapter für...
...Rücksitze in Flugzeugen...
...und ein Klinken auf...
...USB-C-Anschluss...
...das Ganze direkt irgendwo...
...Kasten aussieht, fühlt sich auf jeden Fall...
...sehr leicht...
...ich finde, das sieht aus wie für so ein Fernglas...
...plastisch, plastisch...
...und hier haben wir die Kopfhörer...
...das ist wirklich sehr sehr kuschelig in dieser Kiste...
...dankeschön, danke für den Sub...
...bei so Voraussicht gehen wir da schon mal ans Limit...
...unter dem Bügel steht Filter...
...wobei hier der Filter reinkommt...
...ich glaube, wir brauchen die Anleitung...
...oder die App, eine Maschine hinzufügen...
...die wiegen aber ja schon was...
...Headphones...
...pass mal auf, jetzt funktionieren die Kopfhörer nicht unabhängig...
...du brauchst immer exakt die App...
...und genau alles richtig konfiguriert...
...du kannst nicht einfach mal sagen...
...hey, ich paire das mal kurz per Bluetooth...
...mit was anderem...
...und ich sehe es schon kommen...
...das ist wahrscheinlich von der Handhabung her grausam das Ding...
...uns hinzufügen nämlich...
...ich finde es schon mal gut, dass es nicht annimmt...
...dass ich das Ding jetzt erstmal...
...was ich gerade für 1000 Euro neu gekauft habe...
...erstmal auflade...
...welches ist der Airflow Button?
...der ist offenbar auf der linken Seite...
...achso, das ist dieser hier...
...mit dem Ventilator drauf...
...Bluetooth Lampe ist angegangen...
...jetzt paaren wir uns...
...open settings on your mobile device...
...ist auch schon connected...
...so, jetzt soll ich die hier abschrauben...
...das war einfach...
...was hat sie jetzt gemacht? Ich habe nicht aufgepasst...
...einfach den Filter reinlegen...
...gute Spaltmasse wie ein Tesla...
...Filter habe ich...
...setzen Sie auf...
...prepare your visor...
...das kann man hier so rausziehen...
...wo war der Airflow Button? Der war hier dran...
...das sieht schon hardcore dämlich aus...
...jetzt sind wir schon auf Maximum...
...wo muss der denn ran?
...ich bin nicht zu blöd...
...wahrscheinlich...
...der hält nicht vernünftig...
...danke für den Sub...
...aber so ist ja mein Mund frei...
...das sieht schon hardcore dämlich aus...
...mal davon abgesehen...
...das sieht nicht aus...
...als wäre es FFP2 kompatibel...
...ich will ja nicht hoffen...
...dass wir das demnächst wieder brauchen...
...aber es sieht nicht so aus...
...das ist wahrscheinlich...
...einfach so ein Dyson Staubsauger in klein...
...es soll mich nicht berühren...
...aber es geht nicht...
...also hier unten...
...drückt es immer auf meine Unterlippe...
...gut, aber...
...hilft ja nichts...
...die Brille beschlägt auch ein bisschen...
...aber wir können ja die Frischluft einschalten...
...ich kann das nicht so weit bewegen...
...dass da ein Fingerbreit Abstand ist...
...ich hoffe ihr habt kleinere Köpfe...
...so, da war Luft...
...ich höre ein leichtes Surren...
...es fühlt sich so ein bisschen an...
...als hätte man irgendwie ein...
...das sieht schon hardcore dämlich aus...
...muss man mal sagen...
...das Technikgerät gekauft...
...und würde jetzt so ein bisschen...
...einfach aus der Verpackung atmen...
...es riecht alles...
...ein bisschen nach neuer Technik...
...oh, das brauche ich...
...China-Chinesen-Technik-Geruch...
...in der Nase den ganzen Tag...
...und ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht giftig...
...auf jeden Fall sagt mir die App...
...dass die Abgase um mich herum gut sind...
...und wenn ich mit euch rede...
...dann bewege ich mich hier offenbar...
...in dem empfohlenen Limit der Lautstärke...
...die ich höre...
...aber der spannende Teil ist ja jetzt auch...
...man hört aber den Propeller...
...den Ventilator die ganze Zeit...
...das stelle ich mir ultra nervig vor...
...wenn im Zug jemand neben mir sitzen würde...
...und das Ding dreht dann hoch...
...auf maximale Lautstärke...
...und du hast im Zug nebeneinander die sitzen...
...also mal abgesehen davon...
...dass mein Kopf einfach zu groß ist für die Teile...
...und ich das nicht ohne Kontakt hier hin bekomme...
...aber so kann ich da drunter...
...immer noch Luft holen...
...und ich darf nicht weiter runterziehen...
...weil sonst geht es ab...
...es sieht ein bisschen wackelig aus...
...oder? Guck mal...
...es sieht ein bisschen...
...funnig, wackelig...
...ja billig aus, oder?
...das nicht weiter runterziehen...
...weil sonst geht es ab...
...jetzt wollen wir mal den Sound hören...
...gut, der will erstmal weiter aufgeladen werden...
...um den...
...betreiben zu können...
...ich lade die erstmal auf...
...und dann...
...probieren wir den nochmal richtig aus...
...so, von wegen Aufladen...
...ich habe den ganzen Test in der Zwischenzeit...
...über die Bühne geschaukelt...
...ich war damit mehrmals bei uns auf der Baustelle...
...übrigens gibt es Live-Berichterstattung von der Baustelle...
...auf Haus Schabernack bei Instagram...
...weniger was um Kopfhörer geht...
...mehr um die Baustelle an sich...
...ich war damit auch immer...
...es sieht schon wirklich blöd aus...
...muss man sagen...
...statt um zu sehen, wie sehr man angestarrt wird...
...und kleiner Spoiler, die Antwort lautet...
...sehr...
...ich habe sie bei meiner Arbeit und im Rest des Alltags getragen...
...und kleiner Spoiler, die Antwort lautet...
...sehr...
...und ich habe Meinungen dazu...
...aber erstmal zur Hardware selbst...
...die Kopfhörer...
...sind mit 670 Gramm...
...relativ schwer...
...ich fand sie trotzdem einigermaßen komfortabel...
...auch bei meinem großen Kopf...
...solange ich sie einigermaßen stationär getragen habe...
...oder beim normalen Gehen...
...bei schnelleren Richtungswechseln...
...zieht einem die Trägheit die Masse...
...die Gegner vom Kopf...
...Trägheit der Masse könnte auch...
...der Titel meiner Autobiografie werden...
...jedenfalls kommen die ins Rutschen...
...wenn es...
...irgendwie ans...
...Kopfnicken, Laufen...
...zum Rennen, zum Joggen ist das nichts...
...das Visier dagegen...
...ist super leicht...
...das Geklapper, wenn ich das höre...
...das wirkt wie...
...3D-Druck von AliExpress gekauft...
...und wirkt...
...sogar ein bisschen billig...
...den Eindruck habe ich auch...
...vor allem auch...
...dieses Gummiplastik hier oben...
...diese Lippe...
...sieht ganz gut an...
...das Teil selber...
...soll aber ja jetzt natürlich nicht auch nochmal zusätzlich...
...den Kopfhörer nach vorne ziehen...
...und es muss eigentlich...
...nicht mehr machen als die Luft...
...die in den Ohrmuscheln reingezogen...
...einmal gepflegt, durchgefiltert...
...ich hoffe das Sound taugt...
...ich meine ernsthaft, für 956 Euro...
...kann man einen ordentlichen Sound erwarten...
...und durch diese Lufteinlässe...
...ins Visier geblasen wird...
...ein bisschen zu formen...
...um sie nach vorne zu lassen...
...damit sie dann durch dieses Netz hier...
...in deine Schleimhautöffnung...
...diffundieren kann...
...ansonsten gibt es...
...einen kleinen Steuernippel...
...zur Musik- und Lautstärkesteuerung...
...oh, da würde ich nicht mit klarkommen...
...das ist mir zu...
...ich glaube das ist mir zu...
...feinmotorisch...
...tatsächlich ganz gut gefallen, weil er wirklich haptisches Feedback bietet...
...die Vertiefung, wo das Visier drin festhält...
...und auf der anderen Seite ist...
...der Gebläseknopf...
...um die vier Stufen durchzuschalten, von aus...
...über stationär, bis zu hoher Aktivität...
...denn die Idee ist...
...die Menge an Luft...
...das macht ordentlich Krach, der Lüfter...
...die du gefiltert brauchst...
...hängt davon ab, wie aktiv du bist...
...ansonsten sind hier überall Mikrofone...
...zum Telefonieren, das klingt dann so...
...so, jetzt gerade läuft der Lüfter auf Stufe 3...
...einmal ohne das Visier auf...
...und zur Geräuschunterdrückung...
...da kommen wir gleich zu...
...das kann mit einem Bluetooth-Chip nur mit einem Gerät zur Zeit verbunden sein...
...was für ein...
...960 Euro Kopfhörer...
...nur mit einem Gerät...
...sogar mein 5 Jahre...
...oder wie auch immer alter...
...neues...
...Comfort-Dings, wie auch immer das heißt...
...kann glaube ich...
...5 oder so...
...in meinem Fall in dieser Ausstattungslinie...
...im Jahr 2023...
...einfach nicht mehr standesgemäß ist...
...die Fernstecherbox, der Samtsack...
...und die Adapter für...
...Klinkenstecker und...
...die Fluglinien...
...Geschichte sind...
...also bin ich nicht der Einzige, der denkt, dass das aussieht wie für ein Fernglas...
...nur in der Absolut Plus-Variante...
...des Kopfhörers dabei...
...die du aktuell exklusiv...
...über Dyson beziehen kannst...
...für 60 Euro mehr als die normale Fassung...
...die bietet dann eine andere Box...
...und kostet 900 Euro...
...wo dieser Käse eben fehlt...
...aber immerhin bekommst du...
...für 900 Euro...
...ich brauch die Premium-Variante...
...für 960 Euro...
...dass da ordentliche Kabel und Adapter überhaupt dabei sind...
...sind die von allen guten Geistern verlassen...
...oder wie? Ach, er meint...
...gleichzeitig verbunden...
...also das geht bei meinem...
...bei meinem Headset kann man 2...
...gleichzeitig verbinden...
...und der erkennt anhand des Sound-Outputs, welches Gerät dran ist...
...aber das funktioniert manchmal nicht richtig...
...also ich hab das schon öfters gehabt...
...ich hab auf meinem privaten Handy...
...Musik angehabt...
...und dann gab es einen Teams-Anruf...
...auf dem Handy von der Firma...
...und dann hat das Umschalten nicht richtig funktioniert...
...obwohl ich die Musik gemutet hab...
...bekommst du für diesen Preis...
...sehr schöne, hochwertige Kabel...
...ich will hier gar nicht super lange...
...auf dem Klang herum reiten...
...der ist in meinen Augen...
...kein Grund für diesen Kopfhörer...
...aber auch keiner dagegen...
...also er klingt ordentlich...
...er hat 3 Klangprofile, die grob tun...
...und das kann ich dir ganz einfach beantworten...
...wenn du Bock hast auf eine möglichst...
...Linux-artige Umgebung...
...dann nimm einen Mac...
...vorausgesetzt du kannst da Sachen nachinstallieren...
...der Unterbau von einem Mac...
...ist immer noch deutlich Native-Unix-Linux-artiger...
...als es WSL und Windows...
...drumherum sein könnte...
...und was sie sagen...
...es sind große Treiber verbaut...
...aber andere Kopfhörer...
...für weniger Geld klingen...
...mindestens genauso gut...
...also wenn du einfach nur gute...
...Over-Ear-Kopfhörer mit Geräuschunterdrückung suchst...
...dann würde ich eher zu den aktuellen...
...Sonys greifen...
...wenn du gerne etwas schweres...
...auf deinem Kopf haben möchtest...
...dann kannst du auch als günstige Alternative hierzu...
...zu den Airpods Max greifen...
...ich hätte auch nie gedacht, dass ich die mal...
...als günstige Alternative...
...als günstige Alternative hierzu...
...zu den Airpods Max greifen...
...kostet nur 570 Euro...
...ich hätte auch nie gedacht, dass ich die mal...
...auf meinem Kopf greifen würde...
...was die Dyson aber tatsächlich bieten...
...ist der mit großem Abstand...
...befriedigendste Ton beim Wechsel...
...zwischen den verschiedenen...
...Geräuschunterdrückungsmodi...
...der ist recht satt und inspiriert...
...von den Klängen der Staubsauger...
...und irgendwie macht er jedes Mal...
...ein kleines bisschen Freude...
...nicht nur in meinem Gesicht...
...sondern auch bei anderen Leuten...
...die die ausprobiert haben...
...die Geräuschunterdrückung selbst...
...und auch wenn die da irgendwie...
...Steine gesägt haben...
...entspannt...
...einen Podcast hören...
...ich war dann halt der Arsch...
...der neben den Bauarbeitern steht...
...entspannt...
...und auch wenn die da irgendwie...
...Steine gesägt haben...
...entspannt...
...einen Podcast hören...
...ich war dann halt der Arsch...
...der neben den Bauarbeitern steht...
...und auch wenn die da irgendwie...
...entspannt...
...einen Podcast hört...
...aber es ging...
...ich würde sagen, auch an dieser Stelle...
...stolpert der Dyson so noch nicht...
...ich meine, dafür, dass er preislich...
...über allen anderen Kopfhörern thront...
...die ich eben genannt habe...
...ist er auch hier deutlich von der Spitzenposition weg...
...was die Geräuschunterdrückung angeht...
...also die Airpods Pro 2 oder die Airpods Max...
...leisten da auf jeden Fall mehr...
...die Sonys leisten mehr...
...die Bose...
...der Transparenzmodus, wo du die Umgebung...
...über die Mikrofone nochmal wieder darauf...
...wiedergegeben bekommst...
...klingt ziemlich gut...
...muss ich sagen...
...das kriegen wenige so gut abgestimmt...
...der Modus wird übrigens auch automatisch aktiviert...
...wenn Ritter Kunibert...
...das Visier öffnet...
...das unterbricht Musik und den Luftstrom...
...und schaltet in den Transparenzmodus...
...dass ihr euch mit dem Gegenüber unterhalten könnt...
...das ist alles ganz nett durchdacht...
...aber...
...ich würde sagen, kommen wir zu dem...
...weswegen wir eigentlich hier sind...
...dem Alleinstellungsmerkmal des Dyson Zone...
...die Dyson Zone...
...grenzen dich mehr von der Außenwelt ab...
...als jeder andere Kopfhörer...
...neben deiner eigenen Klangwelt...
...hast du eben auch deine eigene...
...Frischluftzufuhr...
...neben deiner eigenen Klangwelt...
...hast du eben auch deine eigene...
...die hat schon ein bisschen verwirrt geguckt...
...Frischluftzufuhr...
...eine Frischluftzufuhr...
...die dir in die Atemwege gelüftet wird...
...und wie ich schon in dem Unboxing gesagt habe...
...riecht es am Anfang einfach...
...stark nach einem Technikgerät...
...und das geht auch so schnell nicht weg...
...nach einer Woche...
...intensiver Nutzung...
...ist es dann langsam verflogen...
...und ich bin mir nicht mal so richtig sicher...
...ob das gesundheitliche Folgen hat...
...das Ganze so...
...gerichtet...
...einzuatmen...
...erstmal schön AliExpress-Technikgeruch...
...schön ins Gesicht gepustet bekommen...
...so viel Dreck eingeatmet...
...dass ich jetzt drei Jahre lang...
...nur noch gefilterte Luft einatmen muss...
...um wieder bei meiner ursprünglichen...
...Lebenserwartung zu landen...
...aber das ist eigentlich gar nicht...
...der Punkt den ich machen wollte...
...aber was ist eigentlich der Punkt...
...den ich machen wollte...
...Dyson hat ja bei der Vorstellung gesagt...
...dass sie seit sechs Jahren an dem Zone...
...herumentwickelt haben...
...dass das jetzt keine schnelle Antwort...
...auf Covid ist, sondern...
...einfach schlechte Luft...
...es wäre auch eine ziemlich schlangsame Antwort...
...auf Corona gewesen...
...rausfiltern soll, um da wieder...
...schön leben zu können...
...und gesellschaftlich...
...würde ich sagen...
...sollten wir nicht dazu übergehen zu akzeptieren...
...dass wir da überall Abgase haben...
...und dass wir jeder unseren eigenen...
...Luftfilter vor die Nase schnallen müssen...
...gut, das hilft aber jetzt...
...jeden Einzelnen nicht...
...wenn man das jetzt nicht möchte...
...der Dyson Zone misst auch...
...wie viel Stickstoffdioxid in der Luft ist...
...und zeigt es dir in der App an...
...und dieses giftige Gas...
...kommt eben vor allem aus Verbrennungsmotoren...
...so gesehen ergibt es schon Sinn...
...dass man den vielleicht in den Städten...
...erst mal rausfiltern will, zumindest aktuell...
...der Sensor...
...ich muss euch ehrlich sagen...
...vom Ansatz her...
...finde ich das Produkt gar nicht mal blöd...
...lauft mal um den Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof...
...und atmet dort nochmal in manchen Ecken...
...gerade am...
...Ostausgang...
...also hier meine ich...
...Maps, Frankfurt, Hauptbahnhof...
...also gerade...
...wenn ihr...
...äh...
...Chat geht, ich bin verwirrt...
...sollte es hier unten nicht was geben?
...
...oder muss ich...
...erst auf Maps klicken?
...ja...
...so...
...Layers...
...nein, das hier ist der Hauptbahnhof...
...gerade wenn man am Hauptbahnhof...
...hier rausläuft...
...hier raus auf der Seite...
...ist das der Ostausgang?
...wenn du auf der Seite hier rausläufst...
...vom Hauptbahnhof...
...also da...
...gerade runter wo der Parkplatz ist...
...da stinkt es dann teilweise schon...
...also hier ist der Ausgang...
...da stinkt es dann schon...
...gerade wenn du hier vorne dann auch noch rumläufst...
...so hier am McDonalds und so vorbei...
...da stinkt es teilweise echt krass...
...
...das McDonalds ist da?
...nein...
...der McDonalds ist hier irgendwo...
...
...ich war da schon lange nicht mehr, aber...
...McDonalds ist nicht hier...
...Maps...
...ja...
...und hier unten ist auch oftmals abartig...
...das einzige...
...generell ist um den Hauptbahnhof rum abartig...
...also ich finde das Produkt an sich...
...gar nicht mal so blöd...
...wenn man in solchen Regionen unterwegs ist...
...das einzige was ich halt daran nicht gut finde ist...
...es sieht halt echt blöd aus...
...
...exakt nur das...
...andere Sensoren die...
...in anderen Dyson Geräten verbaut sind...
...z.B. Pollenbelastung...
...VOC oder sonst was...
...ignoriert der...
...Pollenwerte holt der sich dann z.B. übers Internet...
...
...leider oder zum Glück...
...bin ich erst im Frühjahr wieder damit dran...
...und so lange wollte ich jetzt mit dem Test nicht warten...
...im Frühjahr fliegen die Pollen wieder...
...hol ich die dann nochmal raus um zu sehen...
...wie gut das wirklich in der Praxis ist...
...die Filter filtern natürlich trotzdem...
...mehr heraus...
...als die Sensoren anzeigen...
...du siehst es nur nicht schick in der App aufbereitet...
...was du aber auch siehst...
...ist wie laut es...
...innerhalb und außerhalb der...
...Hirnmuscheln ist...
...allerdings waren auch diese Werte...
...manchmal etwas fragwürdig...
...weil er mir...
...teilweise auch Gespräche als so laut angezeigt hat...
...wie die Bohrhammer...
...Bohr...
...kommt ja auch immer ein bisschen auf die Entfernung an...
...es gibt 3 aktive Belüftungsstufen...
...und die Möglichkeit das Ganze auszuschalten...
...und die Tatsache...
...dass neben deinen Ohren...
...2 kleine Lüfter drehen...
...die machen Geräusche...
...das hörst du...
...also ja wenn man gegen Pollen allergisch ist...
...könnte ich mir das durchaus als sinnvoll vorstellen...
...und ich würde sagen...
...das ist so ein klassischer Laptop Lüfter...
...du hörst ihn je nach Stufe von leisem Rauschen...
...bis zu...
...aufgeregterem Luftschaufeln auf Stufe 3...
...und zweitens...
...wenn sich physikalisch etwas...
...in den Kopfhörern bewegt...
...und in diesem Fall auch mehrere tausend Mal pro Minute...
...dann braucht das Strom...
...vor allem wirst du das merken...
...beim Kopfdrehen...
...frag mich jetzt bitte nicht...
...wie sich das so physikmäßig nennt...
...aber drehende Objekte...
...wenn du die kippst und so...
...die haben ja so eine gewisse Widerspenstigkeit...
...die wollen sich ja nicht kippen lassen...
...und umso schwerer und umso schneller...
...die sich drehen umso weniger...
...ich könnte mir vorstellen...
...dass du das sogar merkst beim Kopfdrehen...
...neben dem Metall...
...das hohe Gewicht der Kopfhörer...
...da sind natürlich ganz ordentlich Akkus drin...
...das bedeutet auch...
...dass wenn du den als reinen Kopfhörer benutzt...
...der dreht...
...ich hoffe mal zumindest...
...dass es mal 24 Stunden...
...sagen wir mal 8 Stunden hält...
...weil...
...du müsstest ja schon mal einen Tag damit überstehen...
...ansonsten ist es ja unsinnig...
...und also mal rein von Kopfhörern...
...also ich glaube meiner...
...der nur Noise Cancelling macht...
...der hält 30 Stunden oder so...
...der hält ewig...
...ich lade das alle Lichtjahre mal auf...
...aber ich benutze den auch nicht so oft...
...50 Stunden Musikwiedergabe...
...wenn du anfängst zu lüften...
...ist der Akku nach 1 bis 4 Stunden leer...
...1 bis 4 Stunden...
...das ist ja nix...
...da kannst du ja nicht mal einkaufen gehen...
...das macht das ganze Ding unsinnig...
...ich war ja bis jetzt...
...außer dass es bescheuert aussieht...
...war ich ja gar nicht so abgeneigt...
...ich hätte es mir nicht gekauft...
...bis jetzt fand ich es eigentlich ganz innovativ...
...auch wenn es teuer ist...
...und billig aussieht und doof aussieht...
...aber 1 bis 4 Stunden...
...das ist wirklich zu wenig...
...da kriegst du den Tag nicht mit rum...
...was ist denn ein Luftfilter?
...ja ein bisschen sowas wie das...
...was du im Staubsauger steckst...
...nur halt wo die Luft dann durchgeht...
...und Artikel rausfiltert...
...je nach Stufe...
...wenn es gut läuft wohlgemerkt...
...da der Kopfhörer selbst keinen Ausschalter hat...
...was?
...war der bei mir wohlgemerkt...
...nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe...
...Sekunde Sekunde...
...wenn es keinen Ausschalter hat...
...956 Euro...
...ja...
...kann man schon mal...
...auf einen Ausschalter verzichten...
...das ist ja unsinnig...
...war der bei mir einfach...
...oft leer...
...bevor der überhaupt anfangen konnte...
...das Budget war eindeutig zu knapp...
...Luft zu filtern oder Musik wiederzugeben...
...das Ausschalten...
...funktioniert nämlich absolut...
...nicht zuverlässig...
...und das ist sehr schade...
...weil du dich nicht drauf verlassen kannst...
...wenn du sie aus diesem kleinen Köfferchen hier holst...
...dass sie dann voll sind...
...ja es bräuchte keinen Ausschalter...
...wenn das Ding...
...automatisch halt in Standby...
...und sich ausschaltet...
...wenn...nix...
...aber anscheinend klappt das ja nicht richtig...
...das war auch von dem Surfer-Video gestern...
...Bauarbeiter möglichst wenig...
...unnötig nerven möchtest...
...dann aber erstmal eine halbe Stunde wieder ins Auto gehen musst...
...und dein Kopfhörer aufladen...
...ist das in dem Fall unangenehm...
...aber aus Nutzersicht ist es einfach...
...im Alltag eine Katastrophe...
...ich hatte das ein paar mal...
...du kannst die dann auch am Kabel betreiben...
...wenn du länger arbeiten möchtest als...
...1 bis 4 Stunden...
...oder wenn sie eben in der Box leer gelaufen sind...
...auch das nicht zuverlässige Abschalten...
...aber beim Autofahren nervig...
...weil dann der Kopfhörer im Kofferraum...
...sich hin und wieder das Bluetooth-Signal vom Auto geklaut hat...
...aber was macht er denn jetzt...
...wenn er läuft...
...und mir fehlt natürlich das Equipment...
...um das super professionell zu untersuchen...
...also bin ich eben auf der Baustelle rumgelaufen...
...während da Wände rausgeschlagen wurden...
...und alles gestaubt hat...
...teilweise Steine gesägt wurden...
...kann ich sagen...
...ich hab in dem Moment nichts mehr...
...verstanden oder mitbekommen...
...die Frage ist...
...ich mein...
...dieser Staub auf der Baustelle...
...das ist ja tatsächlich auch schon ein bisschen grober...
...da sind wahrscheinlich...
...auch in 1 bis 4 Stunden...
...die Filter voll...
...das setzt erfahrungsgemäß...
...bei dem Dyson Staub...
...sogar dann natürlich recht schnell die Filter zu...
...ein Neuersatz kostet 20 Euro...
...ich hatte jetzt in dem Absolute Plus Package...
...einen Ersatzfiltersatz...
...auch für 950 Euro ein Ersatzfilter...
...das ist ja großzügig...
...und auch als wir versucht haben...
...den Luftzug...
...mit einer Nebelmaschine zu zeigen...
...ja...
...der pustet hier auf Stufe 3 schon ganz ordentlich...
...und von dem Nebel...
...kommt auch nichts im Visier an...
...wenn du sie über die Ohrmuscheln einziehst...
...ich würde sagen...
...du bekommst auf jeden Fall gefilterter Luft...
...als ohne den Dyson Zone...
...die Dyson Zone...
...ich habe mich noch nicht für einen Artikel entschieden...
...und ich kann dir nicht sagen...
...ob der wirklich alles Giftige aus der Luft filtert...
...das könnte ich nur auf die harte Tour rausfinden...
...und im Zweifel nur ein einziges Mal...
...und wenn es dann nicht klappt...
...könnte ich das Video nicht mal hochladen...
...und ihr hättet auch nichts davon...
...ich kann dir aber sagen...
...dass die Luft dadurch nicht mehr nach...
...Brauch, Abbruch oder Furz riecht...
...wenn du das Teil trägst...
...und ich finde der Hinterhals auch nicht schlecht...
...aber 1 bis 4 Stunden Akkulaufzeit...
...das ist einfach zu wenig, dass es sich lohnt...
...wenn dein Kopf so groß ist wie meiner...
...dann sitzt das Visier aber nicht ganz optimal...
...und auch bei anderen...
...wurde der Zwischenraum unten schneller...
...kann man nicht einfach normale Kopfhörer tragen...
...und eine Maske doch, das kann man auch machen...
...wenn man irgendwelche Staubsachen rausfiltern will...
...Geruch kriegst du ja mit einer normalen Maske...
...nicht so gut weg...
...also wenn du beispielsweise öfters mal...
...in Ecken rumlaufen musst...
...wo es stinkt...
...dann bringt dir alleine eine normale Maske ja nichts...
...wie gesagt von der Idee her...
...finde ich das gar nicht schlecht...
...aber die Akkulaufzeit und die Sachen drum herum...
...das ist einfach...
...die erste Iteration davon...
...eventuell sehen wir irgendwann mal...
...was richtig gutes, brauchbares...
...was ich erwartet hätte...
...das war jetzt am Ende auch bei mir...
...eher ein Komfortproblem als eins der Belüftung...
...aber auch mit funktionierender Belüftung...
...hast du eben die ganze Zeit...
...Luft...
...die auf deine Schleimhäute gepustet wird...
...und das ist nicht immer angenehm gewesen...
...also was soll ich jetzt sagen...
...Dyson hat offenbar das Problem gelöst...
...von dem sie behauptet haben...
...dass sie es lösen wollten...
...du kannst in deiner eigenen kleinen Luftzone leben...
...und...
...deine ganz persönliche Luftblase...
...eben auch mit durch die Innenstadt nehmen...
...relativ frei...
...von irgendwelchen Abgasen...
...du musst dann allerdings auch darauf vorbereitet sein...
...dass absolut jeder dich anstarrt...
...sich nach dir umdreht...
...und nach ein paar stichprobenhaften Gesprächen...
...kann ich euch auch sagen...
...dass sie vermutlich recht zuverlässig...
...als Verhütungsmittel funktionieren...
...in meinen Augen ist technisch beeindruckend...
...was Dyson hier gebaut hat...
...und...
...der Kopfhörer selbst ist gut verarbeitet...
...sind alles hochwertige Materialien...
...das Visier ist wie gesagt etwas flimsiger...
...und bestimmt gibt es irgendwo da draußen...
...auch jemanden der das braucht...
...ich bin das allerdings nicht...
...und ich glaube...
...99, irgendwas Prozent...
...von euch auch nicht...
...es gibt besser klingende Kopfhörer...
...für einen Bruchteil des Geldes...
...und so ganz rund...
...läuft die Beatmungszone eben auch nicht...
...nicht nur weil mein Kopf ein bisschen zu groß ist...
...sondern weil langes Tragen dann doch...
...irgendwann ein bisschen unangenehm wird...
...du hast den Plastikduft...
...in den ersten Wochen in die Nase gepresst...
...sie lösen wahrscheinlich ein Problem...
...das zumindest hierzulande...
...die wenigsten so richtig extrem haben...
...durch das Gewicht...
...rutschen sie auch leicht mal hin und her auf den Kopf...
...und durch die komische automatische...
...Abschaltung...
...sind sie vor allem auch oft leer...
...wenn du sie benutzen möchtest...
...Geräuscheunterdrückung, Transparenzmodus und Klang...
...ist alles okay genug...
...dass sie nicht dagegen sprechen...
...sich diese Kopfhörer zu kaufen...
...wenn man sie gerne haben möchte...
...wenn sie dir optisch super gut gefallen...
...wenn du einfach viel Geld loswerden möchtest...
...oder...
...wenn du das Problem hast...
...dieses Visier zu brauchen...
...also wenn du etwas brauchst...
...was dich von Umgebungsgeräuschen abschirmt...
...deine Luft filtert...
...und nicht einfach wie unsere Handwerker das gelöst haben...
...mit einem Gehörschutz...
...und einer Maske...
...und im Zweifelsfall nochmal...
...einem unter dem Gehörschutz geschummelten Airport...
...wenn du genau diesen Anwendungsfall hast...
...dann ist der Dyson Zone...
...alternativlos...
...mir wäre jedenfalls keine Alternative bekannt...
...und wie das immer ist...
...wenn du keine anderen Alternativen hast...
...dann wird es teuer...
...wenn du deine Schleimhäute permanent mit gefilterter Luft trocknen willst...
...musst du eben...
...900 bis 960 Euro...
...auf den Ladentisch legen...
...und ich bin gespannt was in den kommenden Generationen mit dem Dyson Zone passiert...
...aber...
...ein bisschen mehr als Technikshow lustiger...
...noch gespannter bin ich...
...was ihr von dem Dyson Zone haltet...
...schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare...
...und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal...
...Tschüss!
...
MonkaW!
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen. Ich mir selbst auch nicht.
Okay.
Dann gucken wir uns das doch mal an, was hier geht.
Boah, übelst, übelst laut, man.
Was, welcher Cox?
Ray Cox?
Yep, Yep, Cox.
Oh!
Leute, ich halte jetzt die Klappe.
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen ein ernsteres Video.
Wenn ich das hier nämlich schon lese.
Texas Cancer Research Institute.
Das ist so ein typisches
Ami-Shit, ne?
Christ Health
und sowas.
Okay, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, was passiert.
Der kriegt jetzt irgendeine
Strahlenüberdosis, weil die Software kaputt ist.
F
War das die gleichen Krankenhäuser?
Ja, guck mal hier.
Zweimal in Japan.
Das heißt nur japanisch.
Zweimal das, zweimal das.
Und dann hier jeweils die.
Das Ding
gibt es wahrscheinlich bis heute noch.
Software in Kobold
programmiert.
Ecke sozusagen.
Okay.
Was könnte schon schief gehen?
Und das hat es nicht gecheckt, oder wie?
Okay.
Das ist immer ein schlechtes Hin-
Das ist immer ein ganz schlechtes Zeichen,
wenn Random Errors auf solchen Maschinen
gezeigt werden.
Das ist schon der erste
MonkaS Moment, wo ich
echt Schiss hätte, das Ding wieder zu bedienen.
Dass das Ding sowas zulässt. Naja, das ist ja wohl der Bug.
Oh, Dose Input.
Das klingt schon mal schlecht.
Vodafone?
Oh nee, oder?
Och man.
Vodafone, come on.
Haben wir uns wieder eingekriegt, Vodafone?
Okay, ich glaube, es geht wieder.
Okay, ich hab mal kurz
ein bisschen zurückgespurt.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
malfunction54,
Dose Input Error, das hätten sie
ja noch nicht mal übersetzen müssen hier.
Also, in der Fehlermeldung.
Kannst ja beide nicht wirklich zuordnen,
was das bedeuten soll. Ich mein, Dose Input
klingt schon mal ein bisschen MonkaW.
Mr. Moogame, danke für den Sub.
Oh.
1337dog,
dankeschön für den Sub.
Wieso konnte man das überhaupt
einstellen?
Die haben ja nichts verkehrt
eingestellt.
Wir wissen ja noch nicht, was genau ist.
Die haben ja alles richtig
eingestellt aus ihrer Sicht.
Wieso man anpost nach einer
Fehlermeldung? Tja,
wahrscheinlich weil 1986
so viele Erfahrungen
damit hatten.
Ja, wobei, die hatten schon das Gerät 10
Jahre benutzt, ja.
Die trauen vielleicht erstmal dem, was
da steht.
MonkaW.
Wie bei
vielen Unglücken, es kommen mehrere
Sachen zusammen. Es ist nicht nur das Gerät kaputt,
Videoüberwachung und
Audiokommunikation geht halt auch nicht.
After receiving the first attempt
at treatment, Ray later recounted
a feeling of electric shock.
Or that hot coffee
had been poured down his back.
Being his ninth treatment, Ray
knew something was wrong, so he got up from
the table. At the exact same time
the operator unpaused
the Therac-25.
Da hat er aber nochmal Glück gehabt, oder?
Dass er weggesprungen ist, bevor er nochmal
eine Dosis abbekommen hat.
He ran to the door
of the control room screaming and pounded
on the door, visibly shaken
and upset. Oh shit.
Stell euch das, Alter, stell euch
das mal vor.
In der Situation willst du echt nett sein.
...for the incident estimate
that Ray Cox received not
180 rads, but somewhere
between 16,000
and 25,000.
Ray Cox in the following weeks would
feel excruciating pain in his
neck and shoulders, suffer from
several types of paralysis
and eventually die to complications
five months later.
Oh shit. Five other
patients in the US and Canada
would suffer a similar fate.
What could have gone
so terribly wrong in
science?
...
Wenn mehr Informationen und Daten eingepresst wurden, hat der Abgeordnete sich zurückgeschleudert und gesagt, dass die Operatoren die Maschine 2700 Stunden lang testen mussten.
Es wurde später gezeigt, dass der Therac-25 nie getestet wurde, bis er an die Krankenhäuser gekommen ist, in denen er minimale Systemtestungen durchgeführt hat, um zu beweisen, dass es funktioniert, und nichts mehr.
Der Code, der modifiziert wurde,
der Therac-20 und der Therac-25 untergingen keine Regression-Testungen, und der Therac-25 hatte keine Systemlevel-Dokumentation über die Erroren.
Also, was ist passiert mit Ray Cox?
Innerhalb des Therac-25-Codes lief eine Aufgabe, die das Treten ausgeführt hat.
Innerhalb dieser Aufgabe kontrollierte eine Variante, die T-Phase genannt wurde, welche von acht Subroutinen aufgewertet wurde.
Als der Operator zuerst zufällig in die X-Ray-Mode eingestellt wurde, wurde die T-Phase-Variante schnell in die Phase 3, also die Setup-Treatment-Phase, eingestellt.
Während dieser Zeit wurde die X-Ray-Energie auf der User-Interface spezifiziert,
um eine Konfiguration für den Digital-Analog-Konverter aufzuschalten und zu programmieren, welche benutzt werden würde, um die Radiation-Energie dem Patienten zu emittieren.
Auch während dieser Zeit wurden Magneten in Bewegung gestellt, die benutzt werden, um die X-Ray-Beam zu drehen und ihre Ausgabe zu kontrollieren.
Es dauerte etwa acht Sekunden, um diesen Magneten zu bewegen.
Während dieser acht Sekunden ignorierte die Aufgabe zusätzliche Inputs vom User, weil die Datenentriebs-Aufgabe nicht durchgeführt wurde.
Da der Operator in diesem Fall verskillt war und in unter acht Sekunden die X-Ray-Mode in Elektronen-Mode wechseln konnte,
wurden die Änderungen zur Beschreibung nicht von der Maschine beobachtet.
Anstatt Elektronen-Radiation zu erhalten, wie beschrieben, erhielt Ray X-Ray-Radiation in Elektronen-Radiation-Dosen.
... die richtige Bewegung und Mediation durch die Magneten.
Dieser Fehler wird als Rennbedingung genannt.
In einer Rennbedingung hängt die Logik eines Programms auf einer Datenbelegung ab,
die von zwei separaten Threads geschrieben werden kann.
Die Rennbedingung existiert, weil es keine Logik gibt, die kontrolliert,
wer zu jedem Zeitpunkt auf diese Daten geschrieben werden darf.
Ich sage ja, es ist so eine Art Multithreading-Problem, nur 1986 in Assembler.
In den vorherigen Versionen des Theracs waren Hardware-Interlocks da, um sicherzustellen,
dass diese Radiation-Level nicht herauskamen.
Aber um den Therac günstiger zu machen, wurden diese Hardware-Interlocks entfernt.
Das System hat sich vollständig auf Software-Checken angelegt, um sicherzustellen, dass dies nicht passiert.
Im Code sollte es erlaubt sein, dass Fehler passieren werden,
die man sich bewusst hat und die man nie prädigen kann.
Rigoröses Codetesten sollte immer passieren, besonders in Systemen,
in denen Leben auf Software-Sicherheit abhängen.
Wenn der Therac-25-Code getestet wurde, könnte Ray Cox immer noch leben.
Die unbekannte Person, die den Therac-25 programmiert hat,
hätte mehr Wissen über Mathe und Computerwissenschaften erhalten können.
Glücklicherweise gibt es eine gratis und einfach zu benutzen Plattform, um darüber zu lernen.
Jetzt wird erst mal Cell-Audit.
Wird erst mal richtig schön Cell-Audit am Ende.
So sieht es aus.
Ja, interessantes Video.
So schnell kann es gehen.
Die Map hier in der Vorschau, die sieht ein bisschen aus wie diese Black Ops-Map auf dem Flugzeugträger.
Bestes, eines der besten Games ever.
Wer es noch nicht gespielt hat, sollte es spielen.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
Was verdient ein Bademeister?
Und Kost.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, sogar schon gesehen.
Wir sehen uns.
Nudeln mit Lachs, Leute.
Bis denn.
See you.